foreign
the select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic will come to order
I want to welcome everyone without
objection the chair May declare a recess
at any time the committee welcomes the
public to this important meeting while
you are here I want to point out to the
members and the audience today that
house rule 11 provides the chairman of
the committee that the chairman May
punish breaches of order and decorum
including exclusion from the hearing all
participants will be required to avoid
unruly behavior and inappropriate
language expressions of support or
opposition are not in order I expect all
parties to these proceedings to conduct
themselves in a manner that reflects
reflects properly on the House of
Representatives as have every one of the
hearings that we've had thus far on the
pandemic
pursuant to rule 70 of the committee on
oversight and accountability and at the
discretion of chairman Comer Mr Jordan a
member of the full committee May
participate in today's hearing for the
purposes of questions
further without objection I ask for
unanimous consent for Mr Frost of
Florida Mr Gomez of California both
members of the full committee to
participate in this hearing for the
purposes of questions
and without objection so ordered
I now recognize myself for the purpose
of making an opening statement
this is our second hearing regarding
pandemic era school closures
we're investigating the decision-making
process behind school closures and the
effects it had so that we can do better
in the future
inherently part of that investigation is
evaluating if the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention followed science
as they knew it or learned it or merely
accepted outside guidance regardless of
available data during its guidance
Drafting and publication process
it's part of the reason that we're here
today
to determine to what extent the opinions
and suggested guidelines offered by in
this case the American Federation of
teachers during the CDC guidance process
were accepted and why they were accepted
Americans are curious to know if the AFT
access was in line with CDC past
practice and if their influence had a
positive or detrimental impact on
America's children
while it's reasonable for the CDC to
seek outside opinions were some opinions
accepted and others not considered
and why or why not
these are questions that we need to ask
to be clear we are not here to attack
teachers the teaching profession or
suggest pandemic era teaching was easy
because it was not
and we all know that
we're here to conduct an after-action
report
established Lessons Learned so that we
can better protect our children in the
future and protect our children's
futures
during this process honesty is
non-negotiable
and the facts should be facts not
political statements
beginning in March 2020 in response to
covid-19 schools around the world began
to close
doctors and scientists didn't know a lot
about the novel virus and decisions were
made based on whatever facts were known
and at the time they were what was known
to try and best save lives
however it became clear in fact
essential long before the beginning of
the fall of 2020 semester that schools
needed to be and safely could be open
for in-person instruction it was
happening
my children have benefited greatly in
every way
academically
physically and mentally from their
schools being open since the fall of
2020.
and when the facts become clear our
decisions must change with them
is important for students
important for parents and important for
teachers
further the facts and science supported
the ability to safely reopen
while children could get and transmit
covid-19 it was rare
while children could die from covid-19
that risk has been estimated as one in a
million some estimates stated that
children actually became 10 times as
likely to die by Suicide a crisis
exacerbated by school closures
and with a wide range of mitigation
strategies covid-19 Transmission in the
school setting was low
schools could have and should have
reopened and again many did
the Baseline question should have been
schools need to be open are we doing
everything we can to make that happen
unfortunately many schools chose not to
reopen despite the science supporting
safe in-person School practices
this all came to a head in February 2021
when the Biden Administration and the
CDC issued its first school reopening
guidance entitled
the operational strategy for K-12
schools through phased prevention
according to reports when this guidance
was issued its recommendations would
keep 90 percent of schools including
almost all of the 50 largest counties in
the country from fully reopening
why primarily because of three
recommendations
the use of community spread
rates to determine reopening
a requirement for routine screening
testing
and six feet of distancing instead of
three feet
none of these based in sound science at
the time yet all directly supported by
the aft
Community spread does not reflect School
spread
data showed that it appeared safer to be
in school than in the community in many
many cases
so if the goal was to get kids in school
and it's essential for America as we
determine things to be essential or not
then why was the recommendation to
follow the community spread data and not
the in-school spread data
which is actually the environment in
question
the AFT is of course allowed to have an
opinion I respect that
but opinion should fully explain how the
opinion was reached
this is how science works
and how science is debated
teachers teach science
in an email on February 11 2020 to
director wilinsky from aft staff
aft takes issue with the current CDC
language that stated
at any level of community transmission
all schools can provide in-person
instruction
seemingly to weaken that statement aft
proposed adding
in the event High Community transmission
results from a new variant of covid-19 a
new update of these guidelines may be
necessary
the CDC obliged and added that edit to
the final guidance
why not in the event of a high in-person
school transmission rather than
Community transmission
they're too different
in an email to
the president of the AFT the AFT staff
prepared a document for the president
for a February 1 2020 phone call with
CDC
aft staff wrote that the CDC should
support the adoption of screening
testing
in notes provided to the president
president Weingarten before the same
February 1 2020 call with the CDC aft
staff wrote emphasize six feet of
distancing the guidance is fairly good
on six feet or more of distance it could
be made stronger right by rebutting
directly school systems that are using
lower standards to keep students in
school
let me say that again basically aft
objected to schools using less than six
feet of social distancing
so the kids could return to school
aft support for these unscientific
mitigation policies calls into question
why I was offering scientific advice to
the CDC in the first place
scientific expertise of the AFT is
called into question and also called
into question is the high level of
access and influence the AFT was
provided by the CDC
in the AFT letter to this subcommittee
on April 19th lawyers wrote
quote releasing guidance on how to
safely reopen schools without attempting
to address the concerns of these
Educators would not only be
irresponsible but also futile end quote
lawyers continue in short the failure to
consult would have been foolish and
self-defeating end quote
to me these statements sound like a form
of intimidation
is this more political than scientific
of course in the letter in prepared
statement that
president weinger submitted today
she mentioned former president Trump 12
times
as best that I can tell
president Trump had nothing to do with
the crafting of aft guideline
recommendations
that's the topic today
the purpose of this committee is to
examine the procedures followed to
decisions made and why what motivated
decisions
and what worked and didn't work
then ultimately
I would hope that we can produce a
product
bipartisan that will guide future
Generations so that we may have the
ability to predict the next pandemic
prepare for it protect us from it and
maybe even prevent it
and in this case maybe even be able to
successfully maximize our children's
education
especially in person education
not just for some of our children
but rather all of our children across
this country
I pray that today's hearing will produce
some of the necessary facts and evidence
that this subcommittee may utilize going
forward in order to achieve our
altruistic goals
I would now like to recognize ranking
member Ruiz for the purpose of making an
opening statement thank you Mr chairman
the kova 19 pandemic has taken a heavy
toll on our nation's students both
inside and outside the classroom nearly
230 000 children Nationwide lost a
parent or primary caregiver to the
pandemic adding to this loss job loss
economic hardship and food insecurity
weighed heavily on families across the
country these stressors in combination
with the prolonged suspension of
in-person learning have had a profound
impact on our nation's youth their
mental health and their academic
performance according to a 2021 CDC
study nearly 45 percent of high school
students suffered so severely from
feelings of sadness and hopelessness
that they were unable to engage in
regular activities nearly one in five
students seriously considered suicide
and nine percent of survey team
teenagers actually try to take their
lives during the previous 12 months
these are alarming statistics and as a
physician an Emergency Physician and a
father I am deeply concerned about this
growing Mental Health crisis among our
youth it is crucial that we address this
as well as the startling declines in
learning caused by the prolonged
suspension of in-person learning and the
psychiatric psychological trauma of the
pandemic and losing a parent
according to a January 2023 McKinsey
report we've been set back two decades
of progress and learning because of this
pandemic and it may take until 2050 to
some for some students to recover
so now is the time to get students the
resources they need to live and learn
healthily and safely so that they can
succeed now and into the future the
Mental Health crisis our students face
and the acute learning loss they
suffered demand a response that is
driven by data informed solutions that
put people above politics
not extreme budget cuts that threaten
our children's health safety and
well-being you see when we invest in
education and prioritize our children's
health we see the results under the
American Rescue plan and the Biden
administration's leadership we doubled
the number of schools open for full-time
in-person learning things to bold
investments in education and school
infrastructure in fact just one day
after he was sworn in to office
President Biden issued a sweeping
executive order directing a whole of
government approach to get schools
safely and responsibly opened
this leadership the American Rescue
plan's bold Investments and strong
guidance created with input from more
than 50 organizations including parents
teachers nurses and superintendents help
get students back in the classroom
sooner and protected our communities
from a deadly novel virus
it is because of these Investments and
this leadership that we were able to
overcome the previous administration's
covid-19 response failures and inaction
that left our nation and our classrooms
unprepared to combat a global Public
Health threat failures such as
downplaying the pandemic calling it a
hoax a political Ploy by democrats not
urgently acting to reduce transmission
not honestly communicating with the
American American public and not
effectively equipping our schools with
the necessary resources to stay open
these actions put high-risk Communities
In Harm's Way led to an estimated 130
000 preventable American deaths and
resulted in the prolonged suspension of
in-person learning these failures should
have taught us all a lesson about what
happens when we leave our schools and
our communities under resourced under
equipped and vulnerable and yet here we
are holding this hearing today along the
backdrop of the Republican extreme
budget plan that makes Reckless 22
percent cuts on critical education and
Health Care programs that serve
Americans Children and Families the
extreme Republican budget would have
disastrous consequences for our
communities such as removing 60 000
teachers from schools serving low-income
students eliminating more than 101 000
Child Care slots excluding nearly 1.2
million children and mothers from
essential nutrition programs and
decimating life-saving mental health
programs this doesn't help our students
suffering from mental health or
struggling with their grades it makes it
worse for them and their parents right
now America's children need our support
they need resources to make up for lost
classroom time overcome struggles with
mental health and live learn and grow in
a healthy safe environment ripping away
critical funding and focusing on and
prioritizing partisan allegations that
seek to vilify our nation's dedicated
teachers will get us nowhere in
addressing the challenges our nation's
children's face instead let's cut the
partisan allegations let's get down to
business and let's prioritize our
children's health and well-being both
inside and outside the classroom and
let's prepare our schools for the next
deadly Airborne pandemic to save lives
reduce transmissions and keep schools
safely and responsibly open
I yield back
I thank the ranking member we'll be able
to have these conversations again when
that's the topic and that's why I
appreciate you setting the stage now
our witness today is Miss Randy
Weingarten Ms Weingarten has served as
the president of the American Federation
of teachers since 2008. in this role she
oversees a union that represents more
than 1.7 million members including
teachers and other school related
personnel
pursuant to the committee on oversight
and accountability rule 9g the witness
will please stand and raise her right
hand
do you solemnly swear or affirm that the
testimony that you are about to give is
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God
thank you let the record show that the
witnesses all that the witness answered
in the affirmative the select
subcommittee certainly appreciates you
being here today and we look forward to
your testimony
let me remind the witness that we have
read your written statements and they
will appear in full in the hearing
record
so please limit your oral statement to
five minutes as a reminder please press
the button on the microphone in front of
you so that is on and the members can
hear you when you begin to speak the
light in front of you will turn green
after four minutes the light will turn
yellow when the red light comes on your
five minutes has expired and we would
ask that you please wrap up
I now recognize Miss Weingarten to give
an opening statement
thank you chair wenstrup ranking member
Ruiz and members of the scuba committee
I thank you for the opportunity to
discuss my members work during the covet
pandemic teachers work creatively often
past the point of exhaustion to teach
and reach their students like Cara
McCormick lions from White Plains who's
here with us today I'm going to ask the
three of them to stand in a minute
school bus drivers drove their routes to
drop off meals and learning materials
like Lisa Rogers from Albuquerque and
School nurses like Beverly Scott from
Cleveland navigated the challenges and
the uncertainty of the global pandemic
with the three of you just stand to be
recognized and I appreciate what the
chair said about teachers and what they
have done during this period of time
now if you have and I know it took some
minutes but if you have Educators in
your lives you know that their priority
is their students to create a safe
environment for all children and to
prepare them for Life Career College and
citizenship we know that kids learn best
in person so opening schools safely even
as a pandemic surged guided the afts
every action and I'm grateful to set the
record straight from the earliest days
of covid the AFT knew that safety was a
pathway to opening schools and keeping
them open we along with parents and
administrators and health officials we
needed clear science-based guidance to
keep students and staff safe in school
and yes it made sense to consult with
the CDC and it was not only appropriate
for the CDC to confer with Educators it
would have been as irresponsible for
them not to and the CDC conferred with
more than 50 organizations about the
guidance but before the CDC and frankly
neither the president at that time nor
Betsy DeVos would confer with us but we
tried to do whatever we could we release
this report in April 2020 a common sense
science-backed plan to open school
safely that same month we worked with
with John King the former education
secretary to focus and combat learning
learning loss 2420 was chaotic and
terrifying the previous administration
downplayed the pandemic
failure to protect Americans had
unbearable costs it's not just the 1.1
million Americans that died of covet
black children died at almost three
times the rate of white children 245
000 children were offered in America and
members of my union died as well Gabriel
Gale was a fourth grade teacher who was
pregnant with her second child when she
died we lost Holly Ann Hoover a nurse
Anthony Harrell a school of Consortium
and so many more and this is what the
AFT did when the Strategic National
stockpile unstocked we bought three
million dollars of PPP for our nurses
and for our teachers in schools we ran
vaccination clinics we convened virtual
Town Halls that were parents and
Educators and mental health experts
together we spent five million dollars
on a back to school campaign to get
people back to school everything from
helping reopening plans back to school
fair is door-to-door visits with parents
Billboards radio ads Etc
our priorities were to open school
safely to keep students and staff and
families safe to focus on student social
emotional and academic well-being and to
get the resources for this we were
fighting for better ventilation yes for
covet testing and for the tools that we
needed and the same was true with
parents
when President Trump left office 46
percent of schools were open for
in-person instruction between the
American Rescue plan and the work done
by the CDC and other agencies and by
Governors and education officials
parents and Educators including our
Union we went from 46 percent of schools
open for in-person instruction in
January 2021 to close to 97 percent open
in May 2021. now teachers want what
students need let's work together now to
help kids recover and leap academically
let's expand Community Schools let's
increase experiential learning and
career connected learning let's address
educator burnout together we can
overcome the effects of this
unprecedented pandemic and I welcome
your questions
and my apologies for being nine seconds
over
quite all right
Miss Weingarten I want to thank you for
being here today and and providing your
testimony I now recognize myself for
questions
and and I sort of apologize in advance
because
um for the sake of time I'm going to ask
some questions where I really just want
a yes or no answer and I would
appreciate it because we're really
interested in process here
so yes or no did the AFT consult with
the CDC on its February 2021 operational
strategy for school reopening
we consulted with the CIA yes or no it's
yes or no please
um Mr chair I'll get to the let me ask
the questions please I'm respectfully
asking you Just Dance answer yes or no
as I'm going through the process my next
question is since you did consult with
them what did that consultation oh I see
what you're saying I'm sorry yeah what
did the consultation look like did the
AFT first Engage The CDC or did the CDC
reach out to you
so what essentially happened sir was
that we were talking to the Biden
transition team before he was sworn into
office
and we did they reach out to you yes
they reached out no the Biden transition
team reached out to us okay and that
include the next CDC director
um not
or anybody who went to work for CDC I
don't I you know something I'm sure I I
don't want to speculate
there were lots of meetings with lots of
people I I don't know I get that I just
don't know I understand that but but
when was the first time you engaged with
CDC in any way shape or form directly
the first time was when they asked us to
do the zoom I think the first time look
I'm 65 years old I don't remember
everything anymore I'm sorry
um I think the first time was remember
the president was I guess the real
really the only question I think they
reach out to you or did you reach out to
them because I know they asked for
guidance from me they reached out they
reached out my my recollection
is that they set up this January 29th
half an hour conference call okay that's
my recollection and um
again yes or no did that include any
direct interaction with CDC director
wilinski
did it you meaning did I talk to her
directly who are your staff that day we
talked to her directly okay and so that
was via Zoom at that time right later on
were there emails phone calls I think
there were a couple of phone calls but
what there also were and I wanted to
just correct the record on this sir
March what what you may not have asked
us for is on March 23 2021
we actually we've actually had several
public letters with the CDC including
March 23 2021 where we actually talked
about how we understood their change in
terms of social distancing two three
feet so we had several
public letters to the CDC because we
wanted to be transparent of everything
that was going on
so again yes or no but did aft ever
provide suggested revisions to the cdc's
operational strategy regarding school
closures or reopenings did you suggest
revisions to their operational strategy
what we suggested sir was ideas
the other letter to the subcommittee
said that the AFT proposed a handful of
edits to the operational strategy is
that right we Provo what happened was
there was one particular edit that they
accepted there were several different
ideas that we proposed the edit that
they accepted was in the if if I may
explain or no yeah go ahead they they
asked us in the January 29th meeting and
you from your document request as you
know we provided documents including all
the emails back and forth between and
amongst staff our staff
I want to get to the point I guess we
know uh two of the proposed changes
right work from home options for
teachers with high-risk conditions
and that if a new variant arose that the
guidance may need to be changed so with
that and again yes or no were these
proposals accepted by the CDC well the
one proposal that was accepted during
the if I may explain during the 20 the
meeting on the 29th
we raised several different issues
we did not we had seen all the former
were they accepted or not I mean what it
was it's not a question when you made
these proposals the two I I suggested
were they accepted by the CDC the
proposal to have at risk first off the
second proposal was not made on January
29th I didn't first sorry the first
proposal about at-risk
um
immunocompromised workers and not that
simply that they would work at home but
there would be accommodations for people
who are at risk that proposal was
accepted okay now you've answered my
question sorry yeah I'm just slow well
if and then if the other if a new
variant arose that the guidance may need
to be changed and then really like what
what else did aft propose
I mean I mentioned those two that I know
of were there other proposals that
weren't accepted yes several and the new
and the proposal about a new variant
arising uh that the guidance may need to
be changed was that accepted so what we
asked for was because there were new
variants right I understand we all know
there were new variants so we said was
The Proposal accepted yes thank you
so before the operational strategy was
finished aft advocated for a school
closure trigger
that's the word in your documents
on January 29 2021 in notes prepared for
you before a call with the CDC your
staff recommended pushing the CDC for a
trigger stating we need an objective
metric for closure dot dot dot triggers
then on February 11 2021 following the
need to push on a closure trigger a
member of the AFT staff emails director
wilinski directly and says
we must however urge inclusion of clear
closure triggers in the imminent
guidance
again on February 11 2021
in an email from your staff they say our
emphasis will follow Randy's statement
push on needing a closure trigger then
in a February 12 2021 email from from
you to members
you mentioned the CDC did not install a
trigger stating while the CDC guidance
does not contain a closure trigger the
guidance indicates schools May temporary
close to inpatient learning in that same
newsletter in bold font
um the CDC is not mandating the
reopening of schools why was that in
bold why was that to be emphasized
the
so which which of these questions do you
want me to answer I'm asking well I gave
statements that are there we had
documents on what I'm asking is why was
why was that statement in bold the
statement that says the CDC is not
mandating the reopening of schools why
would that be in bold I have no idea
thank you
usually means some type of emphasis I
would think but again you know I mean we
you don't recall what at this point by
this point though so what I did was if
you if I may
the document I did
write was our press release
um that day which you're not referring
to where I said that the CDC has met
fear with evidence and that we were
embrasive of the fact that they had
clear
science-backed evidence so that we could
actually reopen schools more forcefully
than had happened before but at this
point schools had been shown to not be a
driver of community transmission
children were not nearly as at risk as
the elderly children rarely transmitted
to adults
but despite all this science aft still
wanted to install some way to
automatically close schools
which deviates from The Narrative of
doing everything we can to get them open
well actually I'm not I'm I'm I have an
Essex sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry at any
point in 2020 after science being came
clear did the AFT push for a trigger to
open schools rather than the clear push
to have a trigger to close schools yes I
did Sir in fact at the Cuomo commission
which was in my testimony the only
commission that I actually stood sat on
myself
we had triggers in that commission and
why the reason we were asking for
triggers which is what the who had about
nine percent Cuomo commission had five
to nine percent the reason we were
asking for triggers was for the same
reasons as you were complaining about
the cdc's February 2012 I'm sorry 2022
guidance as well because we thought that
what they had done with these three
different tranches was confusing and
confusing to people we actually just
wanted so I I think we wanted uh we
wanted a number because most of us are
not scientists so we wanted a number and
then let me just address if I may what
you just said about Community versus
school I I assume let me I'm sorry I
appreciate that and we have your your 25
pages that you sent us and all of that
and we've got a lot of people together
on both sides of the aisle but you just
read is the issues are about school
versus community and I think you're
talking about the two studies are you
talking about the Wisconsin study and
the Massachusetts study well we do we do
have studies that we have documented I'm
not going to go into those all right now
but the fact of the matter is you were
in your Communications that we have now
there is discussion uh to that to that
regard
here's what I would like to do uh you
you referenced uh the Cuomo commission
or whatever I would I would like for you
to present that to us because I could
not find anything where teachers or the
AFT at least in particular through these
communications with the CDC and that's
what we're talking about today the
communications with the CDC not the
Cuomo report so you asked me but you
asked me the question I'm not asking you
a question right please please I will
let you finish
but today I'm asking you about your
Communications with the CDC this is a
process problem this is a process
concern I didn't see anything in that
that talked about opening it was only
metrics for closure that's the point
that's why I'm asking those questions so
if you did something later not
necessarily with the CDC I would be glad
to review that as part of of the record
for this for this body I really would
and I think that that's fair so at this
point I now recognize the ranking member
Dr Ruiz from California for his
questions thank you let me just take a
step back as a public health expert an
Emergency Physician the request to have
vulnerable
immunocompromised workers have
accommodation because they are at high
risk from dying from covid and we want
to make sure that they live through
covid seems reasonable to me
in fact it's pretty good Public Health
practice
the other request of keeping an open
mind and not have a wine one size fits
all because we know how much that this
virus changes it could drastically
change in its properties and therefore
we should be able to respond to new
variants as they come
also seems reasonable seems pretty
scientific in the sense that you know
you don't want to have a
one-size-fits-all because as we're
realizing these variants eventually may
lead to a steady state but they may also
not
and then the third the third accusation
here about wanting some kind of guidance
to open or close is the same thing that
the economists were asking and all the
other organizations in our society were
just that didn't understand all these
different nuances they just wanted some
basic help us understand when to open
when to close when help us understand
this
that
was asked by so many in so many
different sectors not just for schools
but at the end of the day the CDC didn't
even accept that one the CDC didn't even
put triggers into opening or closing
so what are we doing here
so we all agree that the pandemic took
an enormous toll on our nation's kids
learning loss and the Mental Health
crisis facing America's youth are
serious issues caused by multiple
dimensions of the pandemic like a parent
dying from covet and the suspension of
in-person learning done to slow the
spread of a deadly novel virus
especially in high-risk communities
and as a father and a physician I have a
profound appreciation for the magnitude
of these challenges and the importance
of working together to address them
through forward looking policy salute
Solutions
instead
of
discussing policies that can help our
students overcome learning loss or bring
relief to the millions of kids and teens
struggling with their mental health we
are here to examine partisan allegations
by House Republicans seeking to vilify
our nation's dedicated educators
these uncredible allegations will do
nothing to prepare us for the next
deadly Airborne pandemic and keep our
schools safely open while reducing its
transmission
Miss Weingarten the American Federation
of teachers represents 1.7 million
teachers nurses and staff members who
keep our nation Schools running west
steps have you and your members taken to
accelerate learning and support students
mental health which is what we need to
be focusing on following the pandemic
so thank you Dr Ruiz we have done
um many things over the course of the
last three years to do that and I'd be
happy to give you many of them but my
most recent speech in March 2028
talked about two things that we have to
do number one we have to meet the social
and emotional needs of children
children
are really suffering right now and have
been for a very long time but it has
been escalated because of the pandemic
so what we thought was if we do things
like we've done at Wolf Academy in
Baltimore where we wrap services around
schools and as a result this Academy is
now the second highest performing School
in Baltimore if we do more of those kind
of community schools with wrapping
services around my understanding is that
one of your Witnesses in the last
hearing talked about all of those things
we can actually accelerate learning by
meeting the needs of kids and the second
thing is we have to bring joy back to
schooling and things like experiential
learning I start as a high school social
studies teacher in a career tech school
Clara Barton High School in Brooklyn New
York
what we now know is that 94 of kids in
careertech Ed graduate from high school
70 go to college what's the difference
it's Hands-On it's robotics it's debate
it's it's all the things that we need to
do in this new economy let's do more of
that kind of experiential learning and
do things although I know the chairman
is going to give me the same allotted
time that he has I just want to be more
efficient in the questions while we sit
here today under the false pretense of
needing to protect kids from teachers
unions House Republicans are trying to
pull the wool over the American people's
eyes look as we speak speaker McCarthy
is holding America's full faith and
credit hostage so that he can jam
through a budget with Draconian cuts to
programs that kids in each of our
districts rely on for mental health and
academic success for example House
Republicans extreme budget cuts with
Slash funding for the 988 suicide
Lifeline leaving nearly 1 million people
facing his suicide their Mental Health
crisis unable to access support and
stabilization Services House Republicans
proposed this cut at a time when suicide
is the second leading cause of death
among kids ages 10 to 14 and the third
leading cause of death among adolescents
ages 15 to 24. Ms Weingarten how would
cutting funds for resources like the 988
suicide Lifeline hamstring efforts to
address the Mental Health crisis facing
America's youth look we need these
resources we need kids feel so Anonymous
right now and they focus too much on
their devices we need places for kids to
be able to talk
would be are very helpful for kids yeah
in fact it'll make it worse it'll it'll
take the help away and and it'll hurt
our kids House Republicans are also
proposing a 22 percent cut to the Health
Center Program which would cut off
services to roughly 2 million of our
nation's most vulnerable patients and
families especially those who receive
Services through school school-based
health centers for kids with less access
to Care school-based Health Centers are
a critical Lifeline to Primary Care
Services tooth and eye exams mental and
Behavioral Health counseling and so much
more so Ms Weingarten how does gutting
funding for community health centers
including school-based Health Centers
undermine Children's Health and
educational outcomes
look I very much appreciate Dr Ruiz that
I was asked to speak today and talk
about what kids need and talk about it
in the context of what happened in covet
and going forward
all of what you said
we need these services for kids schools
our our centers of communities for our
kids and our families so we need these
Services connected to schools
well you know I I totally agree but
while House Republicans continue to push
an extreme agenda through hyper partisan
investigations
we will guarantee Democrats will
continue to put people over politics and
develop meaningful solutions to the
challenges facing America's kids
we they need our help now with policies
that will help improve their mental
health and their academic success
thank you I yield back
thank you Dr Reese as chair I do have to
comment
I'm a physician also
and there were no partisan questions
that I was asking you I was asking you
about process that's what this hearing
is about
this committee is to address some of the
many things that Dr Reeves was talking
about
that's not what today was about
that's fine if that's what you want to
spend your time and maybe the whole dice
on that side is going to talk about
policy politics and things that we may
debate
I didn't disagree with the guidelines
that you recommended
as you inferred that was not the case I
didn't disagree with them I just asked
about the process
these were guidelines you recommended
these were guidelines you were that were
accepted I'm just trying to go through
the process so that we have a good
process so that your voice is heard in
the proper way and that we are using
science and and that the process is very
clear from the beginning so the next
time the next time we can do a good job
so you can continue the policy to base
which we will have
but that's not what today's hearing was
about doctor and so you will see from
our side we're going to ask about the
process I'm just trying to answer and
just like you would just like you want
me to answer the questions you've asked
I don't I don't mind you answer
questions Dr Ruiz S I don't mind you
asking answering his questions and and
he's right I'll give him the time that I
took and and that's fair that's what I'm
trying to do conduct a conduct a fair
hearing but this is about the process we
are trying to understand because school
closures had such a tremendous effect on
our children
and so can we move forward someday and
have a process that is very efficient
and that we can do it better because
let's face it both sides of the aisle a
lot of mistakes were made along the way
I completely I know if you've seen this
book yet doctor
I now recognize
chairman Gomer of the full committee for
his minutes of questions thank you on
February 12 2021 the Bible
Administration released its first school
reopening guidance which frankly might
be better described as school closing
guidance since it recommended keeping 90
percent of America's schools closed
documents and testimony gathered by this
committee show the CDC and aft American
Federation of teachers work closely on
this guidance
some of aft's suggestions were included
nearly word for word by director
wilinski herself
in a transcribed interview a career CDC
official testified this level of
coordination was quote uncommon end
quote
that's what we're here to find out as
the chairman said why did the AFT get
uncommon access to the CDC in the Biden
Administration according to documents
we've reviewed aft first received a copy
of the draft reopening guidance on
January 27 2021 is that correct no
do you know when you first got copied of
the guidance according to the documents
that we sent to you
we have got we what
we believe is that we got the guidance
from niosh and the draft guidance from
niosh which is a committee within the
CDC as well as the CDC themselves after
the conversation we had on January 29th
is part of the CDC right right we got
they I think you're looking at a
document can I can I see the document
well we'll get them to you
no listen I'm talking I'm not this is I
run a committee too we're sorry we'll we
we're trying to work together we have
five minutes so we're trying to get this
uh get as much out as we can this is
very important I have kids in the public
school system in a school system that
was was shut down longer than average in
the state of Kentucky and it it it's
it's bad parents are mad our kids are
behind we're trying to find answers we
want to prevent the problem in the
future
the draft guidance is Mark pre uh
decisional and says please do not
distribute yet it was provided anyway
now do you know if any other groups the
CDC consulted with received a copy of
this guidance at the time
I have no idea do you know when the
guidance was finally published I believe
the guidance was published on February
12th when asked is it common to send
deliberative or pre-decisional guidances
outside of the government to CDC
Partners a career CDC scientist
responded we may send summaries like the
day before we're going to release
something but eight the American
Federation of teachers got a full
document
and you got it two weeks before
according to our record
and what do you want me to response her
or no
I'll I'll ask a question did aft provide
any draft language to the CDC for
inclusion into this guidance before it
was published the the one so we had the
meeting with the CDC on January 29th
my recollection is that we got a draft
of the guidance after that even though I
think the document that you're reading
has another date on it is it common for
outside groups to send draft language to
the CDC we what we did was we went
through
the areas that we raised because the
presumption was how do we reopen and
keep schools open and we and we talked
about issues of immunocompromised adults
and this is the CDC accept any of that
this is you all proposed the CDC asked
for language on that which we provided
so so that one of the language so so
they asked us for language on
immunocompromised workers and we
presented that language to them
when we were during the interview with
the CDC career employee it was asked if
between 2001 and 2021 had he ever
Incorporated edits or additions that
came from an outside group and the
career scientists responded I don't
remember any assistance so to summarize
uh aft was provided with a full draft
copy of the guidance two weeks before
publication suggested line by line edits
no we did not sir we did not suggest
line by line edits to the document
well
do you remember how many edits that you
suggested we suggested we we suggested
concept sir which we have submitted as
part of the document request you asked
we suggested Concepts including robust
tests do you know how many edits were
included
one do you remember what that edit was
the reasonable accommodation issue and
then in addition about a week later when
we were going back and forth with all of
the groups there were several other
meetings with different groups and
things like that you saw and the
chairman just said this the issue about
um inch about having
um a review if there was a new variant
we had seen someone had leaked language
to either the New York Times or the
Washington Post and so that's when we
suggested that if there's a new variant
there should be a review and there were
variants my recollection is there were
variants at that time so those were the
two things that we suggested in the 38
pages that showed up in the guidance
well I'll uh yield back Mr chairman say
that it it's unusual for political union
to have such a role in in scientific
guidance process and hopefully we can
find more answers in this hearing
now recognize the ranking member of the
full committee Mr Raskin Mr chairman
thank you covid-19 is uh the deadliest
most disruptive Public Health crisis
we've seen in more than a century it's
already killed 1 million 129 573
Americans and Remains the third leading
cause of death behind heart disease and
cancer five people in my family have
coveted right now two sisters two
brothers-in-law and a five-year-old
nephew
and yet this uh default on America's
debt plan would actually try to claw
back money that has already been
appropriated for combating covid-19 and
promoting public health so I've been to
some weird hearings in this Congress Mr
chairman but this one might be the
weirdest because it's convened in order
to accuse a federal agency of the crime
of Consulting with American citizens
Miss Weingarten you are the elected
president of 1.7 million members of the
American Federation of teachers you
represent double the number of people
any of us do and definitely a lot more
teachers and I need some Enlightenment
right now because I'm baffled as a
member of the select subcommittee on
covet in the last Congress I was
involved in trying to address this
plague when it started and I remember
this specific debate uh very precisely
so let's talk about process no leader
was more outspoken or more forceful than
you were Ms Warner Garden in not only
demanding but developing specific
strategies to safely reopen America's
schools I remember your school reopening
plan developed with health and education
experts released in April of 2020. I
don't know if that's the one I remember
it's the first one I ever saw it was in
the middle of all the terror and panic
when Donald Trump had no plan at all and
was still spreading disinformation about
covid-19 just disappearing by Easter and
encouraging people to try quack medical
cures and aggressively defending his
friends in the Chinese Communist party
in July I remember the effort you led
with the Nea the American Academy of
Pediatrics and the school
superintendents to advocate for safe
resumption of in-person school at the
start of the 2020 2021 2022 school year
and you gave a specific blueprint to
reopen schools in November and you
continued all of this even after the CDC
released its operational strategy in
February of the next year and when I
went back to Google this to confirm my
memory I found nothing but a bunch of
op-eds you wrote demanding School
reopenings across the country countless
speeches and articles about your
advocacy here's one I found New York
Times about you with the headline and
I'd like to submit it for the record the
union leader who says she can get
teachers back into the schools I don't
know if you remember that one from
February 8 2021 it's about how you were
on the front lines of saying let's get
the kids back into school so I'd like to
submit that for the record Mr chairman
look my question for you is why are you
of all people being scapegoated today
by the Republicans for doing the exact
opposite of what you were actually doing
during all of that time how did you get
my friends mad
look
maybe it's because we try to do
something that nobody else was trying to
do we asked the president of the United
States the then president
I'm sorry Congressman Raskin I'm just we
spent every day from February on
trying to get schools open we knew that
remote education was not a substitute
for opening schools but we also knew
that people had to be safe and maybe
it's because I live in New York City I
live near a hospital
every other minute there was a ambulance
there was Terror our members were
terrified others were terrified and what
we were simply looking for was clear
scientific guidance and when we couldn't
get it we did it ourselves and we worked
with doctors and we worked at others and
we just tried to get it out there okay
now all of your efforts took place
without any support from the federal
government on the contrary president
Trump never produced a school reopening
plan while he did produce the worst
record of per capita civilian deaths of
any developed country in the world
education secretary DeVos never offered
any guidance for a safe return to school
and continued to undermine public
schools in countless ways so how did the
chaos and recklessness in the Trump
Administration undermine your efforts to
advocate for a safe Nationwide reopening
of the schools what essentially happened
was that because it was such chaos and
such conflicting information and because
at the beginning of the pandemic saw
many of frankly are activists who were
in schools had died people were fearful
and so what we thought to do was how
could we make very tangible
layered mitigation so that people saw
ways of reopening schools I agree with
Dr wenstrup that when schools had
layered mitigation they were safer than
in the communities but we were looking
for that layered mitigation to keep our
kids and their teachers and their bus
drivers safe and that was what we were
trying to do we knew that remote
education was not a substitute we knew
that kids were not eating the way they
needed to we knew that adolescents were
not developing the way they needed to
that's why we need to do thank you very
much I yield back Mr chairman
thank you I now recognize Miss malitakis
from New York for five minutes a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the teachers the bus drivers power
professionals who have joined us today
and speaking with the teachers the
principals and the parents in my
district they think it was a great
disservice that schools were closed for
as long as they were in some cases up to
two years
um your union as we have found through
the committee's investigations
undoubtedly played a role in ensuring
that these schools would remain closed
far longer than they should have and we
saw indoor dining and bars operating a
50 capacity the schools were still
closed we saw private schools open the
public schools were still closed while
countries in Europe such as Sweden and
Germany would reopen their schools just
months after the virus pandemic began it
would take almost two years as I said
including in my district New York City
we now know that in February of 2021 the
CDC would allow for the American
Federation teachers unprecedented access
to to help draft guidance and would
adopt in some cases almost line by line
aft edits including direct language to
install a trigger which was mentioned
earlier ensuring that schools would
remain closed and making it more
difficult and as possible to to resume
in-person learning it's no secret that
your union your local affiliates spent
20 million dollars on political
donations with nearly all of the funds
going to Democrats in Liberal groups in
the 2021 cycle as the debate about
reopening schools raged and I think it
is a question that we have as whether
you had this type of access because of
those contributions we don't see the
parents being asked their opinions or
the private schools being asked their
opinions on School reopenings uh in fact
I know my principal's Union also was
supporting schools to reopen after a
reasonable period of time
but after lobbying for and securing 122
billion dollars in the American Rescue
plan to safely reopen schools after
after another after 60 billion had
already been allocated through the cares
act the AFT still continued to push for
schools to be closed
private schools opened a year earlier
than the public schools did in New York
City you got 190 billion dollars to
reopen schools safely but guess what as
of November do you know how much what
percentage of that funding was actually
used
on that 190 billion I know
um I I know
um that in New York in September 2020
because as you know quite well we both
are from the same city
um that we opened and the UFT and the
principles Union and the then mayor did
open every single School in 2020. I
don't know how much yes no no in
September of 2020 in every single school
was open yeah but the triggers were put
in place that you know you had a couple
of of cases and the whole entire schools
were shut down but my question is do you
know you lobbied for the 190 billion
dollars in the cares package you
actually blame Republicans for voting
against the American Rescue plan because
you needed that money so badly to reopen
the schools but guess what only 15
percent of that money was spent as of
November
so it means you didn't need that money
and Republicans actually have been
Vindicated in the sense that we were
right all this inflationary spending and
actually didn't even go to to what it
was supposed to go to but I'll say this
the damage has been irreparable to our
children right and and in New York City
which you and I care about very much 50
are now failing their reading exams 70
are failing their math exams one in
three children K through three can't
read at their grade level
New York is now lowering their test
standards as a result
all right and this is a this is by the
way a state where we spend more per
student than any other state in the
country over 25 000 per student
and we're seeing these this horrible
results
um and I think it the school closures
had a lot to do with it uh obesity is
another problem we're seeing mental
health you know the the suicide
statistics this tweet you even
acknowledge that remote learning
I could see you squinting you can't see
sorry but that's all right and you
tweeted out in 2023 what we have seen in
public education is that technology
can't replace teachers remote education
didn't work in part because you have to
have relationships you have to build
trust yes
but yet your union continued to advocate
for these schools to have triggers to
close to keep them closed unlike private
schools
um and by the way some of that money
that 15 percent that was spent from that
190 billion it was not spent to reopen
schools it was spent for CRT for
implicit bias for anti-racism training
for restorative justice programs
especially in cities like ours in New
York City
are you disappointed that the funding
that was meant to reopen schools were
spent on programs like that instead
well first off let me just say that I
over and over again as representative
Raskin said
wanted schools to reopen and wanted them
to reopen safely and there were monies
that were used in terms of that we
needed far more money in terms of
testing and monies that were used in
terms of that the guidance was about the
presumption and the guidance of both the
Cuomo commission guidance as well as
this because the Cuomo commission
guidance was what governed New York City
and that guidance was about reopening
schools as to the money spent for
programs my understanding is that under
the American Rescue plan 20 of that
money was for programmatic work and one
of the pieces of programmatic work was
curriculum and another piece was how do
we help address the emotional and social
needs of kids and that's what the money
was used for okay so you still to this
day believe it was a good use of money
to use that covid that was supposed to
be meant for reopening schools for for
CRT and other type of training well
congresswoman I I don't we don't teach
I now recognize Ms Dingle from Michigan
for five minutes of questions thank you
Mr chairman and thank you to the witness
for her attendance today I'm concerned
about this hearing I quite frankly am
here to learn I share all my colleagues
concerns on both sides of the aisle
about the impact of this pandemic on our
children I just do not believe we should
be scapegoating unfairly uh one
institution that represents a we all
support our teachers and I I think that
there's very unfair uh scapegoating
going down here I regularly met with
teachers throughout my district both
private schools and public schools and
uh to a person while many of them were
fearful about not infecting their kids
the teachers wanted to reopen the
schools and I want to remind this
committee that director Lewinski was
questioned regarding this topic at a
March 2022 hearing before this left
subcommittee under Mr Clyburn in a
response to questions from then-ranking
Member Steve scalise director Lansky
noted that the CDC consultant with over
50 organizations prior to releasing the
school reopening guidance and that this
ranged from parents group to
superintendents to Boards of Education
as well as aft and my understanding is
that responses received thus far from
recipients of the Germans March 28th
letters confirmed this assertion
assertion director valensky also
explained that the CDC allowed the
groups more time than usual to offer
feedback due to the importance of
schools reopening safely she noted that
within months of the guidance being
issued the percent of schools had safely
returned to in-person learning Rose from
46 to 60 percent and I'll remind my
colleagues that in January 2021 roughly
half of school districts were open
that's when President Biden took over
and by the end of May over 95 percent of
schools were offering in-person learning
so and candidly
um I don't personally think the input
provided by afd and that was adopted by
the CDC was unreasonable the first
proposed edit sought to address an issue
that the cdc's first draft did not
mention at all which was how to
accommodate immunocompromised teachers
when returning to in-person learning my
colleagues accusations aside I struggled
to see how that was unreasonable our
nation has entered had entered a new
phase in the recovery of the pandemic we
have now look around we're in this
committee room without mass largely
thanks to the efforts of the body and
administration but remember when we're
where we were then we have to keep in
mind that it was January and February of
2021 the first vaccines had only been
authorized for emergency use a few weeks
prior at this point there was not enough
vaccine Supply to meet demand and only
23 million doses have been administered
in the United States meanwhile the death
toll was over four hundred thousand
under these conditions to suggest that
immunocompromised teachers might require
some degree of workplace accommodation
not only does not seem offensive it
seems compassionate and fair as anyone
who is immunocompromised with loved ones
can attest
and the second edit that they proposed I
think is a matter of Common Sense they
suggested that if a new variant were to
emerge and cause high Community
transmission Mr chairman I know that
there is a difference for you between
school school and Community but
communities do impact what's happening
in the schools that and if it was more
deadly that we would want to revisit our
Public Health guidance it didn't say
close the schools again or keep the
schools closed so I don't think that
that was unreasonable and I'm also going
to remind people that at the time in
late 2020 and early 21 schools had a
lack of resources I was on the phone
every day finding masks and gloves and
tests for my teachers there was chronic
under divestment in schools and
education it resulted in overcrowded
classrooms there were windows that
wouldn't open poor ventilation systems
that were incompatible with coveted
safety measures and the rollout of the
vaccine was just beginning so I you know
and I'm going to remind you with Dr
Scott Gottlieb who was the former
Commissioner of FDA under President
Trump kids are less susceptible to the
infection and less likely to transmit it
but less susceptible does it means
they're not susceptible and at that time
he agreed that the country needed to
take measures to make sure that the
coronavirus didn't become an epidemic in
children so can I ask one question or am
I out of time Mr chair
to so despite
the pandemic's health risks especially
in hop hot spots Miss Wenger were you
ever given guidance by the Trump
Administration on how to safely return
to in-person learning no and that's part
of the reason why we kept on pushing at
it and frankly between the Rockefeller
Foundation Dr Shaw Hawaii
um penned an op-ed with about the need
for surveillance testing that we could
reopen schools with surveillance testing
even before the vaccines and with the
work with the Cuomo Administration and
and gov then Governor Cuomo and actually
work with Larry Hogan then Governor
Hogan we were working with Governors we
were working with superintendents
because no one at the Trump
Administration would work with us in
terms of how to reopen schools safely
thank you Mr Tara yield back
now recognize Dr Miller Meeks from Iowa
for five minutes of questions uh thank
you Mr chair and let me just remind
everyone in this room in this committee
that the vaccines that we have touted
numerous times on both sides of the
aisle were developed under the Trump
Administration and were available uh in
November of uh 2020. let me also say
Miss Weingarten on not for not for
teachers Miss Weingarten I recall very
distinctly and was in those uh hearings
as the teachers union lobbied in order
to get teachers moved to the front of
the line for vaccines on April 19 2023
your Council on your behalf sent the
select subcommittee a 10-page letter
attempting to rebut previous work on
this subcommittee and statements made in
previous letters I'm sure other members
will touch on various aspects of these
claims but I want to focus on one in
particular on page four of your letter
you round about say that the American
Federation of teachers has scientific
expertise and is therefore well
positioned to opine or and science-based
school guidance
so on your science-based expertise can
you tell me that were you aware of
Publications by the American journal and
Pediatrics in the summer of 2020 that
indicated that children had very little
to no transmission of covid-19
um I presented that to our state
legislature as a state senator for us to
reopen schools in Iowa which we reopened
uh half and half uh in the August of
2020.
did your scientific experts that you
said during this hearing
um did your scientific experts present
to you that is of June of 2020 among 1.8
million children in this age group do
you know how many died from covid
so sitting here right now today
um doctor I don't know how many I don't
have that number in my head yeah zero do
know on July 20th 2020 Swedish and
Finnish Public Health agencies issued a
public report comparing the two
countries concluding that closure or not
of schools has little if any impact on
the number of laboratory confirmed cases
in school age children did your
scientific experts
provide that data to you well
um doctor or or representative
what we were presented with was
documentation including from the
pediatricians Association and including
from doctors like Dr Kelly Henning who
worked
um so did they present you data that
showed children were a very low
transmission very low risk of death we
knew that children did they present to
you data from other countries that
showed continuing in-person schooling
was in fact safe for children and safe
for teachers well we were presented with
data thank God that showed that kids
were less had less covid yeah was not
influenza and I can certainly understand
that education we totally know it was
spent I reclaimed my time ma'am I
understand that you know the education
system has a great deal of expertise
with influenza and the challenges of
influenza and the contagiousness among
children however influenza is not
coveted did your experts present to you
August 7 2020 the CDC published and mmwr
study on covidnet data from March 1st
2020 to July 25th 2020 which clearly
established the low risk to American
children in the analysis children
comprise less than 0.1 percent of
hospitalizations and
0.0005 percent of associated covid-19
mortality
did your experts present that data to
you to be able to
develop your assessment for whether or
not schools should reopen so
may I answer
I'm waiting so what are experts showed
us and that's why I was giving the names
of our experts is that they showed us
the two reports the one from
Massachusetts and the one from Wisconsin
and we also saw the reports from the
other countries I don't know if I saw
all of them that you saw that show that
when you had this layered mitigation
there was much less Transmission in
schools that that we saw and that's part
of the reason why we were confident that
if we had the layered mitigation the
layered mitigation relationship with
influenza and I'd say that uh perhaps in
the future we could we could get
different experts but because what I'm
doing is as a physician as seven
Physicians on this panel challenging
what your experts said and uh and as we
continue to learn from covid-19 Doctor
what the medical facts were okay you
know these facts are non-negotiable
ma'am the fact is schools were
relatively safe places for both students
and Educators well they were these are
scientific questions that a scientific
organization should be able to study and
answer and the eight TF is not aft is
not a scientific organization not only
my doctor I'm a former director of the
State Department of Public Health and I
know how important it is to work with
stakeholders to bring people to
consensus but I would say that the AFT
was out of its league in this regard
so that
the effect on children has been vast and
to have no remorse on closing schools
and keeping them closed for the length
of the time is unconscionable thank you
Mr chair I yield back
I now recognize Mr mfume from Maryland
for five minutes of questions thank you
very much Mr chair and I want to thank
the ranking member Ruiz for having us
here my thanks to you Ms guangarden
um my point of order let me just point
out the fact that we claim to love
teachers we claim to care about teachers
but we don't really Embrace teachers we
talk the talk but we never walk the walk
and this Congress in previous congresses
are replete with instances where that
has been shown to be true
now I just want to point out the
presence of a teacher who's here before
she slips out of this door
and some of you will recognize it
she was the 2015 JFK teacher of the year
a year later she was selected as the
national teacher of the year from
Connecticut and we are happy that she is
a member of our ranks and a
representative from Waterbury Johanna
Hayes thank you very much for being here
so let's not get it twisted
if teachers are important we ought to
act like it and we ought to stop all of
this castigating
finger-pointing accusations innuendo
about went wrong all kinds of stuff went
wrong during the pandemic nobody got it
right because we were moving in real
time
I serve as a member of the business
committee the small business committee
do you have any loans went out that
shouldn't have gone out and we're trying
to reclaim them now because people just
in real time weren't doing what they had
to do and how many accusations come down
to that we just can't continue down this
track and you know I just don't like
angry people who use bully pulpits to
make other people look small if there's
some issues and there's some complaints
that's fine but the way we present what
we're doing underscore is really who we
are or more importantly who we are not
now my teacher taught me do unto others
as you would have them do unto you I
wouldn't want to be a witness that just
got the you know what smacked around out
of them for coming here to testify to
this group now this pandemic has had a
real and Lasting consequence we all
agree on our students on our teachers on
our nation and there's still a lot that
needs to be done to make sure and ensure
that we're making up for lost classroom
time that's really the bottom line here
how do we make up and catch up and how
do we stop pointing fingers getting
families the support they needed then
and need now is important and then
helping schools to recover and to
rebuild and to help students get back on
track but the solution to these issues
does not lie in politically charged
hearings that mislead the American
people and have nothing nothing to do
with advancing the protection of
Children's Health their well-being or
their education so I want to go back and
reiterate and be deliberately redundant
of what my colleague Miss Dingle brought
out and correct again this testimony by
reminding us that the transcript of the
hearing that took place one year ago in
this committee
when Ms walinsky came and testified
under oath to this committee and was
questioned by members of the committee
about consultation
she said they consulted with over 50
organizations not just with the American
Federation of teachers 50 organizations
dozens of stakeholders including dozens
of parent groups and school boards and
superintendents and National
associations of School nurses and others
to come up with the guidance that we're
here talking about today they didn't
just go to aft and say what do you think
if they'd done that everybody would be
correct here in lambasting what took
place they sought to get the broadest
amount of information they could and
that's reasonable very reasonable in
fact it's something that we expect will
happen because we want great input it's
also startling to me that even as this
committee's holding this hearing today
supposedly
well let me take that back because I I
don't want to judge their motives
anybody's motives but as we are holding
this hearing today out of concern for
Americans children
some on the committee are threatening to
defund the American education system in
the upcoming budget
now I don't understand that is that a
sleight of hand or is that deliberate
budget cuts 22 percent totaling 3.1
billion
in different areas of Education that
will affect children are all under
assault so I'm glad that you're here
miss lion Garden I suspect that you know
that nobody's going to sort of treat you
with kid gloves but continue to tell the
truth over and over and over again and
in the end we hope and pray that the
truth will run out and went out
gentleman's time has expired I now
recognize Miss lesko from Arizona for
five minutes of questions
thank you Mr chair first I do want to
thank all the teachers throughout the
United States for their work educating
our children it's really important I
remember some of my teachers very
vividly that taught me things
I think what we're here for today is try
to analyze what we did right
what we did wrong
I'm very thankful that we're all here
today we don't have masks we're not
sitting apart you know six feet apart
from each other so I'm thankful for that
but I do think that we did some things
wrong
and one of those things that I believe
we did wrong was keeping schools closed
for too long I have grandkids I remember
when they were sitting in front of their
laptops at home and my daughter was
trying to work remotely and teach help
teach the kids remotely it was insane
quite frankly it was a very difficult
situation the thing that I don't
understand it it's confusing to me and
so some of my questions are going to
relate around this is in many states
like the State of Arizona
the schools opened up
and they had not teachers there in the
schools but they had lower wage School
Employees that would watch the kids on
their laptops being taught by teachers
remotely and that really puzzles me
because I'm like well why would it be
that these employees are less
susceptible to covid-19 than teachers
maybe you can help me understand that
Miss weingartner so thank thank you
representative first off that puzzles me
too
that did not happen in the jurisdictions
we don't represent every jurisdiction we
have 3 500 locals and what one of the
things that has not come through in my
testimony yet is we represent 200 000
nurses and Health Care practitioners in
hospitals we are the I think we're the
fastest growing Healthcare Union as well
as a teachers union and so we've got so
so
one of the things that we tried to do in
the jurisdictions that we were in and
you saw me recognize a bus driver and a
nurse was it was about all of us and
trying to make sure that we were all
going to either be opened and and try to
get more and more kids or you know what
was going on not to separate out two
classifications of people so I I saw
that in your in remarks that you had
made earlier and it's just not ha it
didn't happen in the jurisdictions that
we were in yeah it didn't make any sense
to me and and I completely agree with
you that the work that people try to do
in terms of juggling remote and and was
terrible and that's part of the reason
from April 2020 we were trying to find
what we needed to do in terms of safety
guidance to reopen schools thank you I
just have to I only sorry a minute 44
seconds left the other thing that
puzzled me is that a lot of other
establishments were open grocery stores
were open Walmart was open I assumed
that teachers went to grocery stores and
they went to Walmart so why could they
go there and not go to the classroom
that I don't understand well well part
of the problem was unlike in Europe and
I wish I had the moment to answer this
question unlike in Europe
uh the economy was prioritized in so
many different places in America gyms
bars restaurants and and look it was a
Hobson's choice I think the congressman
if we said it it was a Hobson's choice
but what the difference between schools
and a Walmart is that kids were in
school all day yeah
it it's still mystifies me the other
thing we've already brought up about the
science were you aware that Sweden there
they had no closures of daycares or
schools and that zero Swedish children
died what I am aware of is that Sweden
and Denmark and other places in Europe
prioritize the reopening of schools and
had the layered mitigation that we were
championing
so they prioritized
I have one last question the 14 seconds
I've left I'm a member of Congress
that's it's on two committees that deal
with this the CDC I don't have a direct
number to director wilinski do you
um
I
do not
talk to Representatives you have a
direct number to to director wolinski do
I have director wilinski's direct number
yes yes I have director of windlinski's
direct number well hopefully she'll give
it to me too thank you and I yield back
I recognize Ms Ross from North Carolina
for five minutes a question thank you Mr
chairman
um
instead of using today's hearing to
meaningfully examine the challenges
facing Americans kids in the wake of the
pandemic
this select subcommittee is continuing a
partisan Crusade against our nation's
educators
allegations here are just not credible
and they polarize pandemic oversight and
don't do anything to help overcome
learning loss bring relief to kids
struggling with mental health issues or
pre better prepare us for future health
crises
Ms Weingarten my colleagues have leveled
some mischaracterizations against you
and your organization is there anything
you would like to say to correct the
record
thank you congresswoman number one
the guidance that the CDC did in
February and that they then revised in
March and they again continued to revise
the presumption of that guidance was to
reopen
there was not a presumption to close the
presumption was to reopen with those
safeguards and what has happened in a
lot of places and that's why I raised
the Cuomo Commission because that was
the only commission that I
served on personally was that there were
ways of trying to have this layered
mitigation which is why schools had a
lower transmission rate than communities
that's what we saw in the Wisconsin
study that's what we saw in the
Massachusetts study that's what we saw
in San Antonio that's what we saw in New
York City when it had surveillance
testing we were trying to see what was
an invisible disease
and where people were still getting hurt
and killed and so ultimately our goal
was to have clear guidance so that
teachers in classrooms bus drivers
the School nurses knew but most of us
did not know what this meant and we
needed clear guidance from the
scientists that we could follow because
what we also saw and I'll stop here is
that the more people we got back into
school the more they were comfortable
doing it and so from a June 2020 poll to
our February 2021 poll we saw an
increase of about 20 points of our
members the more they were there the
more they were comfortable with the
layered mitigation the more they were
comfortable being in school teaching
because they wanted to be in school
teaching they knew that remote was not
right for our kids we knew we had to be
in school we just wanted to be safe so
thank you well thank you and I also want
to note that in some of the Scandinavian
countries that have been mentioned there
was also Universal Child Care Universal
Health Care correct paid sick leave and
many of the things that our teachers do
not have in this country I'd like to
enter into the record a letter the
select committee received from the
leadership conference on civil and human
rights condemning today's hearing and
the efforts to smear Ms Weingarten while
ignoring the real challenges that are
facing post-pandemic Mr chairman
okay thank you
this hearing has been way too partisan
under the guise of protecting children
at the same time we're having it we're
talking about a debt limit bill that
would have dangerous cuts to programs
that protect the health and well-being
of some of our nation's most vulnerable
kids
for example
speaker McCarthy's budget proposal
includes a 22 percent cut across the
board for domestic and social programs
including Head Start which promotes
School Readiness for tens of thousands
of underserved infants Toddlers and
preschoolers my mom was a preschool
teacher North Carolina is a leader in
Early Education with the 30 seconds that
we have left Ms Weingarten what kinds of
services does Head Start provide that's
so crucial for the Next Generation
um a child's a separate and apart from
the custodial issues that are so
important when so many women are going
to work separate from that development
of kids kids minds are so Nimble when
there are three four and five years old
and what Head Start does is Head Start
creates helps create that development
and helps create confidence for kids to
be able to actually make those
connections and start applying knowledge
and being confident about themselves and
their well-being thank you Mr chairman I
yield back
I now recognize Mr cloud from Texas for
five minutes of questions
hello thanks for being here I want to
just first Echo the Chairman's
statements from the beginning and just
the general sentiment of this committee
that of course we support and are so
thankful for the teachers throughout our
nation who through a pandemic worked
very hard to to get kids and to keep
kids going now we've learned a lot of
course since and my wife is also a
teacher and whether pandemic or not
there's a lot of work that gets done
I've seen the late hours I've seen the
papers being graded
and we're so thankful for teachers I I
do want to talk about the concern that
some of the guidance was politicized
very early on we knew that covid-19
didn't have the same effect on children
as it did as adults especially
vulnerable populations early data
said that children were unlikely to
suffer serious illness or death as a
result of covid-19 children comprise
less than one I should say 0.01 percent
of hospitalizations and
.0005 percent of covid-19 deaths in a
study published by the CDC and we're
talking about data as early as March
through July of 2020 in June of 2020 the
American Academy of Pediatrics
strongly recommended that all policy
considerations for the opening school
year should be part of should begin with
the goal of having students presently in
school
when former president Trump similarly
pushed for schools to be reopened in the
fall of 22 the ATF activated their
membership and
and I believe you said there was too
little too late at the time in February
of 2021 the AFT celebrated the cdc's
release of the final operational
strategy and it was said for the for the
first time since the start of the
pandemic a rigorous roadmap based on
science
that members can use to fight for safe
reopening uh and director wilinski
assured the public that the operational
strategy was developed by medical
experts and free of political
meddling
just before the guidance came out of
course you had communication and
provided guidance when it came to some
of the logistics of reopening
I I don't
take issue with that I do find it odd
that part of the communication was
communicating the it was scheduling the
communication and the concern that the
union and the Biden Administration might
stand apart from a messaging standpoint
and the need to make sure that you're
coordinating
um in regards of a political
statement are you a medical expert I am
not a medical expert
and
um I wanted to bring your attention to
this because I found this enlightening
as well this is your state of the union
report I'm sure which one which year
familiar to 2020 to 2022
okay so I'm sure you're familiar with
this uh it reads with all the passion
and Gusto of a political Manifesto
there's everything in here on thoughts
from promoting government-run and Health
Care inflation immigration abortion
voting and election law uh efforts to
promoting unionization not just for
teachers but for all Industries Second
Amendment issues weighing into the war
of the Ukraine uh
I was also struck by what wasn't in here
the word political appears 29 times and
always in the context almost always in
the context of dollars spent on
campaigns reading only appears 16 times
and usually in the context of promoting
books that many parents are concerned
about being in their schools science
only appears five or six times in
related to covid math only appears once
and it was in a time when the American
Federation of teachers was advocating
against a community that wanted to
streamline and focus funding on math
reading science and social studies it
went on to talk about how some of the
money is being used Colorado used
solidary funds to maintain the
Democratic majority in the Colorado
House of Representatives the Florida
Education Association and went on to say
for the first time in Florida Republican
voters outnumbered Democratic voters and
it went on to talk about the effort to
reverse that Trend that the union has
Georgia Federation of teachers
contributed to the School Board race in
state democratic causes all that is
allowed and fine but the concern I have
is when the White House comes and says
that there was no political input that
what we constantly see is a an
organization that you're not an
education organization although you have
educations you're not a medical
organization you're a political
organization and that you are weighing
in on on the guidance are you still a
super delegate to the Democratic party
I am still a delegate to the DNC yes
okay which again you have all
Realms to do and and we should
participate I have a concern when the
White House is making decisions based on
political science versus real science I
think my time is up
and I yield back
now recognize Mr Frost from Florida for
five minutes of questions thank you Mr
chairman during today's hearing
Republicans on this committee are
attempting to paint the American
Federation of teachers as a destructive
specialist interest group out to harm
students they are not aft represents our
talented generous and compassionate
Educators who are the backbone of this
nation's child care and our children's
home away from home this is personal for
me my mother's been a public school
educator for 37 years teaching special
education she actually retires this year
and this is Rich it's ironic and it has
no one fooled this is to distract from
the real special interest group that is
the real threat to children all across
this country the NRA and look I
recognize that the pandemic has had real
impacts on American children but make no
mistake for a brief time in this country
children didn't have to memorize
emergency exits children didn't have to
practice active shooter drills more than
they're doing fire drills children
didn't have to walk around with a Kevlar
backpack or figure out what they have to
do if a shooter were to come into their
classroom students are begging for
Congress to have the courage to act on
gun violence if you care about students
if you care about schools fight for a
world where students are not dying in a
pool of their own blood in the call in
the classrooms that they're supposed to
be learning in if Republicans gave a
damn about America's children they would
pass legislation to end gun violence to
keep students safe to keep teachers safe
to keep administrators safe and the
staff at the schools if Republicans gave
a damn about the Next Generation they
wouldn't be actively trying to cut
funding for your kids school and turning
a blind eye to the gun violence that's
killing children every single day in
this country if they give a damn about
gun violence they wouldn't be going
after teachers over some emails about
school safety from two years ago let me
tell you what people are actually going
through my friend Manuel Oliver lost his
son Joaquin in the Parkland shooting
Joaquin Oliver
in Parkland Florida and when I think
about what our children are going
through and the real threat to them I
think about the autopsy of Joaquin
Oliver
I quote a significant amount of bleeding
the bleeding went into his right chest
cavity and started compressing his lungs
by basically drowning he died in a pool
of his own blood
that is what happened to Joaquin Oliver
that is the threat that our students are
going through
549 children and teens have already been
lost to gun violence this year alone and
yet here we are bearing our heads in the
sand ignoring the problem and refusing
to put legislation on the floor
up ma'am thank you so much for being
here today what impact does a child
living through mass shooting or other
gun related events have on their
development mental health and ability to
learn
look it's terrible
I mean
we represent
the Educators in you in Parkland and the
Educators in
Sandy Hook
and uh
gun violence is the number one cause
of death of kids
and yes obviously we should be doing a
lot more about that
and I just hope that this caring
that I've heard all day long about kids
on both sides it will translate into
what we do today and going forward about
helping our kids yeah that it's that
that this sentiment that I've heard
is actually taken to help our kids and
not just questioning me about
when I talk to Dr wolenski yeah I mean
if we held on oversight hearing on this
and invited survivors teachers students
parents do you think that the committee
would find that inaction in Congress on
gun violence to be appropriate how do
you feel like the parents and the
students would feel look
I
I think 147 work sites or 150 work sites
between April 2021 and April 2023.
I walk the walk with parents and
teachers and children
and they are scared about gun violence
and about the ready access of guns
they're scared I hear it all the time
yeah well thank you so much thank you
for your work and thank you for your
perspective on children their overall
health well-being and development this
is one of the greatest threats to kids
in schools this is one of the greatest
threats to teachers
um and our families in the school system
not whatever they're talking about right
now to score political points but the
fact that our kids are being shot that
if your child and I'm speaking to the
parents of this country God forbid if
your child were to die before the age of
18 the most likely reason is because
they were shot to death I find that
unacceptable but Republicans on this
committee do not and that's why we're
here today thank you I yield back
now recognize Dr Joyce from Pennsylvania
for five minutes of questions thank you
for yielding Mr chairman and thank you
for appearing here today in front of us
Ms Weingarten
throughout the pandemic we all heard
followed the science
in guidance released back in June of
2020 the American Academy of Pediatrics
called for a return to in-person
learning and they further stayed in
their guidance for safe schools and the
promotion of in-person learning quote
remote learning exacerbated existing
educational inequities
was detrimental to educational
attainment and drastically worsened the
growing Mental Health crisis among
Children and adolescents Ms Weingarten
do you agree that in-person learning
provides the best educational
opportunity for students yes
do you agree that remote learning May
exacerbate educational inequities be
detrimental to educational attainment
and worsen a growing Mental Health
crisis in children yes
one of the worst side effects of
prolonged school closures has been
learning loss
is a pandemic associated with learning
loss is that real
well yes of course it's I agree with you
but what but what we also saw
um
um sir is that
in places and and this is what I think
the lccr was getting to in the letter
that they sent to the committee take a
place like la
which actually was closed for the whole
2021 school year and yet its nape scores
for English
increased
technology pandemic is associated with
all one instance
what is associated with learning loss
and that is real what I'm saying is over
Equity equity and poverty and other
things are associated as well this is
what was so interesting about their
results they did a lot of this work they
fed kids they made sure that kids had
reading instruction they made sure that
that kids had internet access they
actually did the equity work that the
lccr has been asking for and that we've
been asking for and what happened please
I'm one limited time in face of that
the pandemic is associated with real
learning loss correct yes or no the
pandemic that there isn't look
kids need to be in school thank you
and their learning is better and the
learning is better in school thank you
we agree on that point the goal now has
to be doing everything that we can do to
provide students with the ability to
recover these losses completely do you
support adding additional time to the
school day to help students get more
in-person instruction time we are
actually doing additional time right I
think that's cool do you encourage your
members to teach during expanded summer
school to help the students get that
necessary what you just described yes
needed in person in fact in fact John
King and I made that proposal in an
April 2020 op-ed to have summer school
even back then because we knew the
importance of kids being together it's
not just academic it's the at it's the
adolescence development and it's the
relationship building I think that's I
think that's so important so be clear
you do not support increasing access to
additional Educational Services to
correct for learning loss that occurred
as a result of the school closings that
your organization has advocated and
supported you are in favor of additional
time in the classroom an expanded summer
programs I would favor that that's why
we are calling for community schools and
things like that we are in favor of
wrap-around services and Community
Schools and having additional time
additional time summer training I think
that's awesome the AFT though is
inherently a political organization in
fact political activism is in your
mission statement is that correct
um academic achievement welcoming and
safe environment it's political activism
in your mission statement there are many
things in our mission statements
including political activities
including ensuring that people have a
voice yes so political activism is part
of who you are CDC guidance especially
guidance based on complex immunology and
epidemiology requires scientific
expertise and earlier in your testimony
with us here today you said most of us
aren't scientists does the AFT employ
any epidemiologist
um yes we actually consulted with
epidemiologists does the AFT employ
immunologists yes we consulted with
immunologists in-house do you employ any
infectious disease specialists we have
people who are industrial hygienists yes
do you have any board certified
pediatric infectious disease specialist
on your payroll not on I in in
Consulting with them yes do you uh have
anyone with experience with treating
novel coronaviruses
um well uh to the extent that there was
any expertise in the country yes
wow I'm a physician and I knew of no one
who had any experience treating novel
coronal viruses if you don't have the
ability I just said to the extent that
it was available there was none
available there was not available yet
you I can give you the names of the
people that we relied on right forward
those to us please
because my time is limited you also
talked about over-reliance of kids
spending too much time on electric
devices and you put up your phone just
like I'm pulling up my phones but they
need to be connected person to person
and I think we can all agree that
removing students from in-person
learning has really accelerated the
issues affecting mental health that you
miss Weingarten have mentioned
repeatedly throughout this and the only
conclusion that I can make as a doctor
as a parent and as a legislator that the
AFT recommendations harmed so many
children and I think we have to learn we
as a select subcommittee have to learn
and we have to move forward when faced
with a crisis like the pandemic was we
have to understand that those who are
not susceptible to this must remain in
school those students have suffered and
were waking up time or making up that
lost time and we need to do that in a
conjoined effort thank you Mr chairman
and I yield
now recognize Mr Cuda from Hawaii for
five minutes a question thank you Mr
chair Miss Weingarten thank you for
being here today as a mother that has
two boys that attend our Public Schools
I experienced firsthand the impacts of
the covid-19 pandemic on my children's
education their learning their mental
health their social emotional
development we witnessed all of us we
witnessed a lot of loss during this
pandemic you talked about it but
students didn't just lose academic
learning as you mentioned we lost family
members others lost a caregiver a parent
a classmate a teacher a friend I'm glad
to see my colleagues across the aisle
talk so much about how they care about
our kids their learning their mental
health however I find it ironic that we
are once again talking about school
closures closures by the way that were
done to keep children safe when the last
administration had no plans in place to
safely reopen them while Republicans
have proposed a 22 percent reduction to
non-defense spending to deal with the
debt limit once again close doors to our
children and their education today we
are talking about the impact of the last
pandemic on learning loss yet I will be
clear I am worried about the pandemic
being created by House Republicans cuts
of these proportions will make learning
loss and impacts to everyday life for
everyday Americans from covid-19 pale in
comparison to what they will soon
experience
I personally struggle to understand how
anybody who cares about our children
genuinely could advocate for these kinds
of cuts Miss Weingarten perhaps you
could offer your view on this how might
Republicans propose budget cuts to child
care funding Educators support nutrition
feeding programs among other critical
safety net programs contribute to a
whole new generation of children
experiencing devastating learning loss
so thank you for your comments and I
hope your kids are okay
the
work that we need to do now
is how we engage kids and how we meet
them socially and emotionally and how we
meet the whole child
there were colleagues here who talked
about obesity one of the things we need
to do when we feed kids in school is we
give them nutritious programs we need to
have that we need to have the social
workers and the guidance counselors that
meet kids needs and families needs
that's why we are proposing a big
expansion so we need more funding not
less for an expansion of community
schools and wraparound services so the
services that all these doctors have
been talking about we can do in school
with kids and Families
I agree and I completely agree we're
looking at a whole of child whole of
family approach when we look at
education and how we are supporting our
kids many of us here in Congress in this
room right now represent small towns
predominantly rural communities like
mine in Hawaii rural school districts
and Rural students suffered greatly
during this pandemic how might the
Republican because that we are looking
at right now disproportionately impact
again our ability to overcome learning
loss address mental health issues impact
academic achievement in our rural
communities across our country
look if you already don't have a
guidance counselor if a guidance
counselor is there for about four or
five hundred kids and you start cutting
Title One and cutting idea and funds for
special needs that means we're going to
have fewer and fewer of them and it
means it's going to get worse and worse
so at the very moment that everyone I
think seems to agree that our kids
matter and should be a priority then the
funding for them should be a priority
absolutely if the Republicans proposed
cuts are implemented it would have a
significant impact on critical programs
and resources available to all of our
children in particular I'm looking at
child care a 22 percent cut would mean
200 000 children lose access to Head
Start slots and another hundred thousand
children lose access to child care now
this undermines our children's basic
foundations for education and how they
will articulate through the system as we
know making it more difficult as well
for parents to rejoin the workforce
contribute to our economy access to
Affordable high quality Child Care is a
critical component I think as many of us
in this room agree to a child's growth
and development again if we are truly
looking at learning loss and saving off
learning loss Child Care is critical it
affords substantial benefits for these
children as they grow and age into
Adolescent and adulthood I should also
know that child could boost Child Care
boost the economy by allowing parents as
I mentioned to once again rejoin the
workforce in contrast to Republican
Draconian custody programs that support
Working Families we have as
Congressional Democrats taking decisive
actions to put Americans on firmer
footing as we emerge from this pandemic
the arpa funds to the state of Hawaii
nearly 80 million dollars actually
helped to keep child care centers open
prevented these children from
experiencing learning loss in Hawaii and
we know this took place across our
country especially our rural communities
I know that my time is up but miss
Weingarten thank you for being here as
we talk about what could be the next
pandemic if these cuts are actually
taking place
thank you I now recognize that Mr chair
I did say to you before I'm you're not
you're not regular no no can we take a
break so I can have a bathroom break yes
we can do that thank you sorry five
minutes okay for votes coming up sorry
I'm sorry thank you yes thanks
thank you
do anything
yeah
this is Thailand
she's an incredible
no I'm a person I'd be like do you have
another pair of shoes in here
she always
like really good
um
thank you Mr chair I know you have a oh
I just wanted to rush
committee comes back to order and now
recognize Dr Jackson from Texas for five
minutes of questions thank you Mr chair
this morning right now I uh I honestly
uh thank you for coming today I don't
honestly know if I even have a question
for you to be honest with you I uh I
just I feel like that uh I don't know
what the point is at this particular
point I think most people know what
happened at this point I think anybody
that's watched what's going on for the
last few years knows exactly what
happened I'm just going to make a
statement I I I just want to say that
you know early on this is this is this
is how most people view this early on
the data showed that children were
unlikely to become infected spread the
infection become ill or die from covet
19. that's a fact data also showed that
school closures social distancing
masking and testing provided no benefit
to the students or their adult Educators
that's also a fact data also showed that
those very actions that I just described
were highly detrimental to the academic
achievement the mental health and the
physical health of our children since
the science the actual science never
supported closing schools we must
examine why and who was behind these
these these detrimental efforts to
promote school closures without any
scientific support support for doing so
we now know that you and your
organization has been documented at this
point edited the draft of this
scientific quote scientific based
guidance on school reopening from the
CDC the document that was used to keep
most public schools are all around the
country closed in fact
I don't think I don't think you were to
blame I think the Biden White House and
the CDC are the ones that really failed
our country the Biden White House and
the CDC should have completely
disregarded any any suggestions from
your politically motivated and corrupt
organization in my mind
but I guess considering your
organization gave millions and millions
of dollars to Democrat candidates into
their liberal campaign committees you
and your organization got anything you
wanted from the bite Administration that
seems to be how it works this is what
corruption in the federal government
looks like the American people have seen
it and they don't like it teachers
unions are supposed to exist to protect
their members and to advocate for
students however your organization the
AFT has demonstrated that what you
actually care about is gaining and
exerting political influence and lining
your pockets with taxpayer money even if
that is at the expense of our own
children since 2020 Congress has
allocated more than 190 billion dollars
to schools across the country through
the elementary and secondary school
emergency relief fund to enable schools
to stay open
much of this money has been unaccounted
for and much of it was spent on woke
social garbage racist CRT programs and
other leftist programs much of it was
provided to increase the salaries of
teachers teachers that were paid to stay
home thanks to your strong advocacy
so big win for you and big win for the
organization keep the schools closed let
people stay home and draw paychecks
demand money from the Biden
Administration to reopen schools use
that money to promote horrible social
programs in our schools once they
finally reopen provide pay increases to
your members with Federal taxpayer money
and lastly use the dues from your
members to pay off the Democrats that
make it all possible this is what
happened I cannot believe that you still
have a job after the role that you and
your organization played in the
destruction of our children over the
last few years I think it's disgraceful
and I think you should be ashamed of
what happened over the last few years
and you should take some responsibility
for it with that I yield back Mr chair
now recognize Dr McCormick from Georgia
for five minutes of questions
thank you Mr chairman first of all I
want to state that I have great respect
for teachers
I mean that sincerely the most
influential people in my life other than
my parents maybe my Marine Buddies
I truly appreciate what they've done for
me over the years
I've spent four years as an associate
professor both the private and public
schools I have seven kids so I have a
little Street Credibility when it comes
to educational experience and and I
spent about 20 years in youth ministry
so I understand the importance of what
teachers do and I sincerely appreciate
the efforts
with that said I just wanted to go over
something that you've already affirmed
which is you'd tweeted at one time what
we've seen in public education is that
technology can't replace teachers remote
education didn't work
uh you did tweet that correct
okay thank you yes I did thank you I I
totally agree with you myself I have I
have tweeted about two hundred thousands
so that wasn't controversial sorry we'll
just continue
um I'm not trying to Corner you believe
it or not I agree with you my son
actually was having problems during this
educational experience where he couldn't
get a teacher to meet with him well into
the pandemic where he was remotely
learning but he doesn't do math so well
he's like his dad and he needed help in
person and even with precautions wasn't
allowed to come in so it really affected
his educational experience and negative
way to the point where he had to drop
out of the class it was it was harmful
to him in that educational experience
just like many other students we've seen
it with countless families across the
Spectrum we've seen a five percent dip
in in white students 13 African
Americans eight percent Hispanics a
great educational disparity that
happened because of this educational
experience that we experienced because
of covid
um
would you agree that
public education is an essential service
yes yes absolutely thank you me too
I was on the front lines of the uh
during this pandemic has treated
thousands of patients first line during
from the beginning when we didn't have
any vaccinations all the way to December
28th my last shift would you agree that
the emergency room Doc is also an
essential service
of course thank you I mean and Sir
simple question we represent about two
hundred thousand get you I get you and I
represent a lot of your doctors and my
sister is in intensive care thank you
thank you for her service so I will tell
her and of course we couldn't do our job
remotely correct as as ER Physicians
well we had over 200 I couldn't do much
no I get you I get you nurses who we
represent who did not do their jobs
remotely and we believed in being in
school that's why I said earlier we
tried from famous firefighters same as
law enforcement everybody has their
their jobs that are essential services
that they can't do remotely and as you
said there are people who came in during
some scary times that that couldn't work
remotely I don't think we're trying to
argue about what is essential Services I
think we all agree on what those are
whether it be a clerk that actually
helps you get your meals or or your
groceries or somebody serving you in
real very real ways and required ways I
think we all agree on those things and I
get that it's scary and I get that at
the very beginning there was definitely
a reason to be overly concerned because
we didn't know how this is going to it's
a novel virus I get it and as we started
to develop things you guys got the wrong
information a lot of times so do we
because it was politicized and some
people who are quote unquote experts
told us things that were wrong even
though they probably hadn't seen
patients since the 90s and people like
myself who are seeing thousands of
patients were censored by the way so you
couldn't get the truth a lot of times so
I understand why teachers would be
scared to go back to school I do get
that but as this developed
and as the evidence became more clear my
concern is that we learn from these
committees
because that's what we're here for
I don't think anybody disagrees that the
whole reason we're here for this from
the for this committee is so that we
don't repeat our mistakes
we had to admit that we made mistakes
we all make mistakes doctors made
mistakes we used to not use NSAIDs we
didn't use steroids we intubated
patients people died because of mistakes
we made during a novel coronavirus that
we learned from
but would you
as the head of this Union
admit that teachers maybe should have
gone back to school earlier with
retrospective information so we don't
make the same mistakes in the future and
leave so many kids Behind look I regret
covid I regret what has happened to you
so I'm just asking questions I want to
learn from this and I know I know what
you regret I have 20 seconds I think
you'd be if you'd let me answer I think
you'd be surprised at my answer okay I
regret
you know I regret the fear that was
there and part of the reason we wanted
clear
um clear information was because we had
a role in terms of overcoming fear I
think this book that just came out
yesterday actually gives us a road map
for what we need to do going forward
because I do think we didn't get it
right I think the ventilation issues the
testing issues actually were more
important than the social distancing
issues I agree with you there were
things that we really didn't get right
film's time has expired I now recognize
Mr Garcia from California for five
minutes of questions thank you very much
Mr chairman uh thank you Mr weigart and
I appreciate all the work first that you
do that our teachers do across the
country I'm an educator myself I'm
married to an educator and so I I
appreciate
um the hard work you know I just want to
re-center ourselves and remind us that
we were went through a massive
disruption to our country to lives we
lost over a million Americans my city
alone lost 1300 uh residents within my
community when I was mayor just right
before I got elected to congress and
this was a a traumatic horrific event
and the largest loss of life event of
the modern era and so this idea that
there aren't going to be mistakes made
in our institutions or organizations of
course is ridiculous there are going to
be Lessons Learned whether it's in our
education sector whether it's in public
health whether it was it was in the way
the government managed on the vaccine
rollout we're going to learn how to make
things better and I want to and I want
to um uplift the fact that teachers were
working under terrible conditions very
situations where they also have family I
want to remember that teachers also had
family at home also have sick parents at
home we're also trying to protect
themselves their loved ones and their
own children outside of the classroom
and so I just want to take that moment
that everybody was scared and trying
their absolute best during the pandemic
The Long Beach Unified School District
was the first it was the largest school
district that reopened schools when we
were open because teachers were
vaccinated because we've vaccinated
teachers early on and gotten the
supplies that they needed and the
resources that they we we often looked
at your school district as a model for
what to replicate thank you and a big
part of that was because we made the
decision early on to double vaccinate
all of our teachers and to ensure that
everyone had access to the vaccine early
we actually were the first school
district the first city to actually
vaccinate teachers in the entire State
of California and vaccination led to
reopening schools first and faster and
so there needs to be more and more
emphasis on that vaccine access I also
just want to note and we you know we've
been mentioned a few times that you know
it was President Trump that was and his
administration that was really
facilitating uh the closures and trying
to get us reopened and it was a total
disaster there was very little support
early on from the Trump Administration
to actually get us support and support
our schools we worked directly with our
schools essentially sidelined the
federal government and and try to get as
much support whether it was materials
whether it was PPE whether it was
vaccines directly to our schools
now I appreciate you mentioning Long
Beach in fact President Biden also named
Long Beach and her school system as a
national model in reopening schools and
we and we appreciate that
um I want to ask you the American Rescue
plan was a lifesaver as you know for
schools for school districts beyond the
American Rescue plan what else should we
should Congress be doing to assist
schools to ensure that in the future
this doesn't happen again and that we
can reopen schools even faster so
several things
number one
what we learn through the end of this
pandemic and I know that there are you
know there are some issues in terms of
you know vaccination or not but 90 of
our members voluntarily vaccinated and
we took a position and you know some
people disagreed and some teachers were
fired because of it we took a position
that we needed to work with our members
work with school districts to get as
many people vaccinated our members
vaccinated even on a mandatory basis as
possible to open schools and just and on
that point and I support that by the way
you know there are there's someone in
this audience here today who disagrees
with me about it you know and so what
I'm saying though is that in a in a in a
pandemic we need clear information we
need clear guidance most of us who are
not scientists need to trust the
scientists to give us clear guidance and
the mitigating circumstances absolutely
let me including ventilation and testing
agree completely and vaccine hesitancy
which we know in fact members of this
very Congress are some of the largest
most vocal vaccine deniers in America uh
does that hurt and would that have hurt
the reopening of schools did that
actually
cause any concerns for teachers on the
ground well look
so
Rockefeller
fella that said we could reopen schools
even without vaccination if we had the
testing and I think during the Omicron
variant we saw that testing really
helped us keep schools open just like it
helped the NFL and just like it helped
the MBA and so I think that there's a
combination of things that we need to
know in terms of what is the measure to
keeping people safe absolutely keeping
people open and finally I just want to
say if we really want to focus on
insurance because there will be in
future pandemic ensuring that schools
today have the resources that they need
correct teachers have the resources they
need that we're actually in reinvesting
in our schools that's actually going to
help to ensure that there's a future
pandemic we can solve it even faster and
learn from our mistakes thank you so
much
I now recognize Ms Green from Georgia
for five minutes of questions
thank you Mr chairman Miss Weingarten
are you a medical doctor I am not are
you a mother
I am a mother by marriage by marriage I
see
um and my wife is here with me so I'm
really glad that she's here right here
with Sharon Miss Weingarten and you
haven't taught school since the 90s so
you're not a teacher anymore I am
actually
representative I'm actually on leave
from my teaching position and this fall
I will be teaching as a guest teacher at
Cornell my alma mater it was when was
the last year you taught in 1997 is that
correct the last time I taught a full
class was June 1997. okay that's been
quite a long time approximately 26 years
ago do you believe in the First
Amendment Miss Weingarten
um I believe in the Constitution
including the first amendment of course
oh great well I'd like to remind you of
one of your tweets here where you agreed
that my suspension on Twitter uh in your
own words politicians shouldn't be
exempt from standards about spreading
misinformation green has repeatedly
shown Reckless disregard for those
standards this suspension is Justified
this is your Tweet just last year
January 2nd 2022 I was suspended for my
statements about covid-19 as a member of
Congress by the way and also I'd like to
point out by by the Emojis by your name
here it looks like you're more of a
political activist than anything clearly
unfortunately you think Ukraine comes
before the United States I'm not sure
what the black Flex is I mean is is that
digital blackface but congratulations on
graduating from school but I'd like to
is about honoring Blackness Wine Garden
I reclaim my time I didn't ask you a
question what I'd like to talk about is
your recommendations to the CDC as not a
medical doctor not a biological mother
and and really not a teacher either so
what you did is you advise the CDC Mr Mr
chairman that is that I mean that's a
excuse me this is my time uh you advised
the CDC to have schools uh provide
remote work options for staff that have
documented high-risk conditions who are
increased risk for for severe illness
from covid-19 to limit the risk of
workplace exposure telework virtual
teaching opportunities modified job
responsibilities environmental
modifications scheduling flexibility
temporary reassignments to different job
responsibilities none of none of your
advice was had to do with to stop the
spread of covid-19 it was is all about
teachers staying home and there was big
results of that let me tell you I am a
mother and all three of my children were
directly affected by the school closures
by your recommendations which is
something that you really can't
understand I'd like to point out let's
talk about the the real effects of this
obviously we know the test results oh
and by the way the you celebrating what
I had said on on Twitter I had said the
children should be in school I had said
the truth that children were not dying
at high rates of covid-19 like older
people were I had also advocated for our
children not for teachers getting to
stay home and kids being forced into
virtual schooling
I advocated for the safety of our
children and for their education but you
as a political activist for the
president of the teachers union were not
advocating for anything good for our
kids and our kids have suffered greatly
as a matter of fact suicides increased
their rates of learning went down
and you know what else happened to him
anxiety depression all kinds of problems
happen to kids and then ironically
here's something that was shocking to me
and I'll bring this up to you
know what else happened while kids were
forced to stay home and you approve of
this the diagnosis of youths with gender
dysphoria surged this is literally 2020
but yet this is 2021.
and this is a problem this is a major
problem and the direct effect of school
closures can be seen here
these are diagnosis diagnosis of gender
dysphoria and you can see it sharply
increased after 20 20 and 21. it went up
the rates went up so kids were forced to
stay home into so-called virtual
learning where they were spending a lot
of time on social media and all of a
sudden we see a direct result of this
and this is a this is a major problem
but the other problem is is you had no
business advising the CDC what the
medical guidelines were for school
closures because now we have a nation of
school children who have suffered
because of it the problem is is people
like you need to admit that you're just
a political activist not a teacher not a
mother and not a medical doctor the only
way it's time yeah and now I now
recognize Mr Jordan from Ohio for five
minutes Mr chairman I I just want to mix
note that um the the decorum of the
attacks on the witness were unacceptable
that a gentlelady from Georgia just did
and so it'd be nice if we didn't attack
the witnesses particularly whether or
whether and making a decision about
whether or not she's a mother you are a
mother thank you for for being a great
parent thank you
your point of order is recognized Mr
Garcia
it's a point I recognize Mr point of
order given that his point of order is
recognized and given that that was not
just cruel personal attacks to miss
Weingarten who loves her children it is
reflective of the cruel personal attacks
to any adopted mother or father who love
their children so I would kindly ask
that those remarks be taken out of the
record
for the sake of all of the parents who
have adopted a child and love them
dearly and see them as their own
it was not a violation the house rules
however your point of order is
recognized I now recognize Mr Jordan
from Ohio for five minutes I think the
chairman um who cares more Miss
Weingarten
who cares more about a child's education
the teachers union or the child's
parents I would say that Mr Jordan or
representative Jordan teachers parents
and teachers care about kids obviously
parents care about their own kids more
than probably anyone else but teachers
and parents are real Partners in
children's education okay that's fine
but so so you would say
but I ask you who cares more you would
say parents
well parents parents care look
and that I'm I'm not here to be in a
competition parents are so important in
children's lives teachers are so
important in children's lives too why'd
you uh why'd you repost and praise the
op-ed that was in The Washington Post
parents claim to have the right to shape
their kids school curriculum they don't
um you posted that and you said this was
a great piece that we should that people
should read head of teachers union
Praises op-ed claiming parents don't
have a right to shape their kids
curriculum you really believe that the
um the headline of that op-ed
was not appropriate compared to the
actual work in that op-ed the work in
that op-ed talked about if you actually
disagree with that you describe the
headline then no I disagreed with the
headline the work in that op-ed talked
about how
um parents and teachers have to have a
role in kids education so the headline
of red parents claim they have a right
to shape their kids school curriculum
they do so that's been what the headline
said I don't you know I uh Mr let me ask
this is straightforward just let me ask
straightforward do parents have a right
to shape their kids curriculum parents
have a right to have a role in their
kids curriculum yes
who are the extremist politicians
you did 25 pages of your written
testimony you had 14 pages your Law Firm
had I think the other 11 and right at
the end of the main body of your written
testimony before you get into the issue
of today about the consultation you guys
had with the CDC you say in this last
paragraph uh attacks by extremist
politicians have undermined teachers in
schools who are the extremist
politicians I think you just heard one
so Miss Green's one of them I think okay
that's that's I think when I think the
issue is the cultural Wars that are
going on in schools right now Banning
books
undermining teachers how about this
statement I don't think parents should
be telling schools what to teach you
just told me a few minutes ago you
didn't agree with that sentiment is that
a statement from that's a statement from
a politician is that extremist I believe
that parents have to have a role in kids
education and in fact when I was
teaching at Clara Barton High School we
had parent engagement all the time who
said this I would bring if you want me
to finish I'll finish I like so many
other teachers used to do I was a high
school social studies teacher I know you
were a wrestling coach I was a high
school social studies teacher my wife my
wife and our kids went to public school
I appreciate good teachers my coach my
high school coach impact of my life I
know and I honor that but we you know so
what I would do and so many other
teachers but I asked you I ask you a
specific question I don't think parents
should be telling schools what to teach
do you know who made that statement
um I don't know
September 28 2021 candidate for governor
in the state of Virginia you know who
made that statement
I don't are you talking about Mr
McAuliffe I am talking about Mr
McAuliffe he made that statement is that
extremist is that an extremist political
statement in fact what I did Mr Jordan
was when I heard that no we know what
you did you endorsed him into a
six-figure ad by your organization when
I did 18 days later when I did Mr Jordan
is when I heard that statement I called
Mr McAuliffe and I told him I disagreed
with him but it wasn't enough to get you
to not do a six-figure ad buy for his
campaign well what the six what the ad
by did was do what we thought Mr cough
was which was paragraph same paragraph
on page 12. I just got a minute I just
got a minute same paragraph on page 12
you say most Americans disapprove of the
culture wars that have saturated
education policy who started the culture
wars
um
I know that when you have Banning of
books like a book about it let me ask
you something let me ask you something
like a book around about Roberto
Clemente like a book about Ruby Bridges
that's wrong
those who think boys should compete
against boys in sports
or those who think boys can compete
against girls in sports which one which
side started the culture War which one
of those positions sir I am talking
about when I talk about the culture wars
I am talking about things like book
Banning I'm talking about things like
stopping teachers from teaching honestly
is it is it starting a culture War if
you think uh literature should be age
appropriate that's not that's not I
believe that literature should be
age-appropriate too okay
I'm out of time thank you Mr chairman
although we're pressed for time because
of votes
I now recognize Mr Gomez from California
but I would recommend and we've
discussed this with the ranking member
in the past especially if you're waving
on you'll be here on time
and I know we all have schedules to keep
but go ahead Mr Gomez
thank you so much Mr chair um really
appreciate it
um
so I I think there should be a broad
agreement we shouldn't Batten books like
that's just flat out pretty uh simple
but I believe my my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle want to distract
and rewrite what happened over the last
several years everything from the
coveted response to uh the massive tax
cut that they gave to the top one tenth
of one percent in this country they want
to change a lot of the The Narrative of
the last not two years but four years
from before that when um president Trump
was in the white house so I want to kind
of focus on issues that I think the
American people really care about if
they cared about children
why aren't they attempt why are they
attempting to cut federal child care
funding by 22 percent that's what their
their budget would do and why do they
want 200 000 children to lose access to
Head Start and a hundred thousand
children uh to lose access to child care
working parents are spending nearly as
much of their income on child care as
they do on housing as a new parent and
founder of the dad's caucus I can tell
you one thing our child care system is
in crisis not only is it an affordable
and inaccessible Child Care uh child
care workers who are predominantly women
of color are severely underpaid and
overworked meanwhile the bite
Administration and Congressional
Democrats have consistently acted to
protect child care across the country
for example the bite Administration
invested around 39 billion from the
American Rescue plan to help children
child care providers keep their doors
open these efforts have helped 220 000
child care programs which employ over a
million child care workers with the
capacity to serve nearly 10 million
children Additionally the president's
budget would expand access to Affordable
high quality Child Care by enabling
states to increase child care options
and by lowering costs so that more
parents can afford care the president's
budget also funds a federal state
partnership that provides high quality
Universal free preschool to support
healthy children Child Development and
insured children enter kindergarten
ready to succeed meanwhile Congressional
Democrats led the fight for increased
Child Care funding in last year's
spending package securing 8 billion for
the child care and development block
grant an increase of 1.9 billion above
the fiscal year 22 enacted level and
before that house Democrats passed Child
Care is essential act which would have
appropriated 50 billion in federal child
care funds Ms Weingart how does adequate
adequately funding our nation's child
care benefit our children's development
and growth
so thank you for that question
congressman
all day long I've been talking about how
teachers teach kids
I am glad that in this pandemic thank
God it did not affect children the way
it felt affected adults
but it's the teachers that teach kids
it's the bus drivers it's the School
nurses but we need help and so when we
have Head Start when we have Community
Schools when we have all these things
that
look like they're on the chopping block
now it's going to make it harder to
teach kids it's going to be making it
harder if you cut a head start for kids
to have a head start when they get to
kindergarten and so when when you cut
Community Schools or the guidance
Services all these things that we need
for kids now because of their
development issues because of suicidal
issues
we need this help we can't do it alone
we asked for during covid for teachers
to be safe and have clear guidance to
have them safe
we wanted to be in school I've said that
over and over and over again today
and I I appreciate that my um two of my
siblings are teachers and San Francisco
Unified they teach there for a long time
until recently they taught a dual
immersion Spanish English right
um and
if you ever had a teacher in your family
or sibling or mother or father you
people recognize that
they give everything oftentimes because
they don't get enough don't have a
enough resources from their own school
they subsidize you know the supplies for
their own students if they see a student
without a coat they give them a coat if
they see a student without
um that they need a little extra help
they'll go out and give a little extra
help on their own time
not not because they're getting paid but
on their own time and that's what the
the teachers have done for our country
so I really appreciate it I yield back
now like to yield to ranking member Ruiz
for a closing statement if he would like
to make yeah thank you uh I appreciate
uh giving closing statements I think we
heard a lot from both sides of the aisle
I think we are very have very clear
differences in methodology and what we
think are priorities for this select
subcommittee and what we want to focus
on I do want to say some things because
we heard from Physicians throughout this
hearing that and I also want to remind
folks I am a physician and a public
health expert and uh and social
distancing has been a long-term Public
Health basic way of lowering
transmission for deadly airborne viruses
it's not only shown in literature but
it's been practiced and
retrospectively and studied even from
the great influenza pandemic that if you
have a virus that spreads through
droplets from your mouth the louder your
Scream the you cough or you even speak
you have Micro droplets spreading from
your mouth so the further people get the
safer they are from transmission so at
the root basis of of keeping people safe
from Airborne droplets people were asked
and sometimes uh
regulated to to stay far from each other
so I really want to defend public health
and public health practice and say that
in the event of of a novel Airborne
deadly pandemic social distancing is one
of the crude and also rudimentary Public
Health measures to keep people safe but
what we want to do for the next Airborne
deadly pandemic is that we want to
create safe environments so that people
can socialize so we don't have to close
the school so we don't have to do these
things to keep students apart from each
other and I think that's what we should
be focusing here today we should be
focusing thinking ahead for that next
Airborne deadly pandemic on how can we
save lives how can we lower transmission
and how can we keep kids safely in
schools so we don't need to practice the
social distancing that has shown to work
uh so look the charge of this select
subcommittee is to understand the kova
19 pandemic so that we can prevent and
prepare for future Public Health crisis
our mission is to get ahead of future
deadly novel viruses with the potential
to devastate our communities so that
none of us have to endure another
pandemic yet today instead of doing the
critical work or the work of addressing
learning loss from the pandemic
that's what most parents are concerned
about today is is my child's mental
health and the learning loss what can we
do today to help these children or the
work of bringing relief to Americans
youth facing a mental health crisis we
rehashed miss weingarten's emails and
her organization's Common Sense feedback
on school reopening guidelines
guidance that as you may recall led to
95 percent of schools returning to
in-person learning just one year into
the Biden Administration look we all
agree that the pandemic took a serious
toll on our nation's kids the question
is what are we doing to help our
students and their parents you know
hyper partisan investigations do nothing
to repair this harm and neither does an
extreme Republican budget that proposes
deep cuts to the very programs intended
to enrich our nation's kids and help
Working Families get by and provide the
mental health necessary to recover
programs like Head Start WIC idea grants
and more all of which will be gutted by
Republicans default on America act so
let me be clear
Republicans cannot claim to be serious
about protecting our nation's kids and
families while pushing devastating cuts
to programs that paved the way for
children to grow and thrive in fact
those cuts do the opposite they make the
problem worse they hurt our children and
our families and it is my hope that
going forward the work of the select
subcommittee will focus on the facts and
lead with the purpose of developing the
forward-looking policy solutions to the
challenges facing our nation
there is still time for us to change
course to discard the partisan
allegations the vilifications of
individuals and organizations to make
partisan accusations and investigations
intended to score some points you know
and to put
people
because this is what we must do
we must put people over politics and
work together to save lives now and for
the future pandemic thank you
I thank the ranking member and I think
he he knows as we have been friends for
some time
we have the same goals
there may be policy debates
we hear that all this group doesn't care
that group does care and I care more
than you and all this type of stuff
the bottom line is
this committee would not have even been
formed if we didn't care right
that's why this select committee was
formed
so weed through all the stuff you may
have heard today
from many ways
our goal is to be prepared next time and
you know what next time we may have a
pandemic that affects kids more than
adults correct and how are we going to
be ready for it correct and that's
really what we're after
we have two years to do this it's a
short time and there's so many topics to
cover
so I hope that as we go through the
process understand the things that were
mentioned we need to talk about we we
plan to talk about all those what
programs are actually working it's our
job for oversight to decide how much are
we spending on things and where is the
money going and is it actually having a
return on investment
because that's a smart thing to do of
course
so you know about your things today like
uh uh oh you don't like these guidelines
as I said to you the guidelines that I
questioned you about as being accepted I
agreed with them
I didn't have a problem with them that
wasn't the issue
so I hope that you can see that we are
working towards finding a process
understanding the process make sure that
we can do things smartly in the future
that's my goal
that's why I wanted to accept this job
when asked to to take it on by the
speaker
look I my family I've got teachers
and I can tell you I know my teachers
from kindergarten through eighth grade I
still know their names
and I still get together with my eighth
grade teacher
you know they mean a lot to me
um even at my age he's still hanging on
but uh you know so uh
we over and over again you know like we
heard implied that I was against those
things I I wasn't I I just wanted to
understand the process and we've had
hearings here with the school nurse
associations represented and we've had
we've had good discussions
now one of the things you said though is
you saw much less Transmission in in the
schools and so in me as a scientist as a
doctor I'm like well then why are you
wanting to base things on community
rates that that didn't make sense to me
so these are questions we want to get to
the answers to and and what data was
used and why did you come to these
conclusions uh you know the the data the
data give us better choices it did and
so you know you mentioned a couple
things that I would like to put into the
record if if we can
uh the written guidance from the medical
experts that you talk to I think it
would be good if we got something from
them for the record well I certainly can
give you their names
um I think that there is I think a lot
of what we did
um sir was we did orally but so I will
give you their names and if I can find
the written guidance we will find it of
course whatever you can do or whatever
they may want to submit and maybe they
can recall what they put together and I
think that would be helpful you know you
mentioned the the Cuomo commission and
uh that you had your suggestions
guidelines I'd like to have that as well
um things that were there for reopening
and you did mention that you weren't
asked by the previous administration
that's fine maybe that's another lesson
learned that uh you know look we're
looking at who are the groups that were
asked to weigh in okay well was it
helpful was it not this is where we are
right now
and so these are legitimate questions
so you got the Cuomo commission I know
you you stated that you had contact with
Dr wolinski and so I would hope that
that was submitted to Dr Lewinsky who
did ask for your input
but let me just just share something
here from Hawaii and it's an exchange
between uh reporters and and our
governor in Ohio
and uh the reporters saying that
Governor dewine speaking during hastily
called televised briefing noted that
almost every school district in the
state agreed to resume in-person classes
by March 1 in exchange for Teacher
vaccines but he said Friday that a
handful of schools where vaccines have
been distributed including in Akron and
Cincinnati have indicated that they will
renege on that agreement and delay
reopening Governor dewine said that
while anyone who wanted the vaccination
in Akron schools has received one school
administrators there aren't planning to
resume in-person learning until
mid-march Governor then was quoted as
saying that's not acceptable either
Governor's remarks came hours after an
announcement by the federal Centers for
Disease Control and prevention that
there's strong evidence in person
schooling can be done safely as long as
masks social distancing and other
strategies though not necessarily
teacher vaccinations are put in place to
protect against kova 19. so when I read
these things
you know it it it's it seems to me fair
to when an explanation as to why several
large public school districts in Ohio
refuse to open in March of 2021 despite
having vaccines distributed thus
compelling the governor to take the
extraordinary
actions to compel them to open and I
just bring up this story because it's
there for further discussion these are
the things we want to look back on and
ask ourselves why why did some schools
not reopen they have the right to to
explain themselves but this is where we
need to go so that we can be wiser in
the future and as I said not this is my
closing time and we're finished we're
finished sorry because I could explain
well this we can talk about that later
you can send me a letter this is this is
where we are with the committee and
we're having votes yeah you know but
this is my closing statement what I'm
saying is that's what this committee is
supposed to be about and I hope it can
be that way through throughout the rest
of it because we're going to be doing
this for a while so questions will will
come up and you can feel free to answer
that to me in writing and I would
appreciate that thank you and uh with
that I would say that this hearing is
adjourned and without objection all
members will have five legislative days
within which to submit materials and to
submit additional written questions for
the witnesses which will be forwarded to
the witnesses for their response if
there's no further Business Without
objection the select subcommittee stands
adjourned thank you